ich bin mal gespannt wie das klappt heute
ich erklär gleich nochmal was ich vor hab, das wird lustig
ich glaube ich werde es verkacken, weil das ist ein thema wovon ich echt kein plan hab
das ist ziemlich netzwerk heavy heute
mal gucken, aber ich weiß erstmal bis twitch überhaupt gecheckt hat dass der stream richtig
honest
exellent, oh jetzt hat twitch kapiert, hat discord mitbekommen dass der stream
funktioniert, das ausmachen, mal kurz gucken ob es discord kapiert hat weil
der bot war vorhin kaputt hat es discord mitbekommen
der cutebot ist kaputt, der hat auch vorhin die video ankündigung
nicht gecheckt gestern gestern ging es noch mit dem stream
cutebot broken af
ich will discord ausmachen, ist erlaubt
exellent, ja twitch notification, telekomausfall was los
ja telekomausfall halt, für den die telekom nichts kennt
für den die telekom nichts kann
was für eine vm umgebung, hier benutze ich vor allem workstation
kannst doch hier jedes x beliebige andere, wobei so viel x beliebige andere
sachen gibt es da ja gar nicht, was gibt es denn was gibt es denn sonst noch
ich meine du hast virtualbox, ja gut kann man wenn es unbedingt kostenlos sein
muss verwenden, kann es vmware player verwenden, der hat dann aber keine snapshots
es gab mal für virtual pc aber ich glaube das gibt es da mehr
tja mir fällt nichts ein wenn ich ehrlich bin, wundert mich eigentlich
vmware hat nicht wirklich ein konkurrent oder? wahrscheinlich ist da so big brain
technik hinter vmware, dass das einfach nicht jeder machen kann
das sieht aus als würde ich chico überfahren mit den emotes, guckt mal ich
sehe das gerade in der forschung, sieht aus als will ich mal katsu überfahren, ne ne ne
will ich das, btf monkawe ja, die liegt gerade auf dem kühlschrank und rollt
sich rum oder kennt würde ich eher sagen und rollt sich ab und zu mal rum
wo kann man denn vm's wie windows 98 downloaden, äh gar nicht, du brauchst ein
windows 98 iso und dann nimmst du eine vmware software deiner wahl und installierst
da windows 98 drinne, also es gibt keine windows 98 vm, ja ich rede jetzt ja desktop
virtualisierung auf windows, da gibt es ja nichts wirklich außer vmware, gesagt
virtualbox was irgendwie ja weiß nicht bin kein großer freund von aber so
wirklich aber so wirklich gibt es ja nichts klar du hast unter linux noch kvm
das was für linux virtualisierung das verbreitetste ist keine frage aber
ansonsten also es gibt es nicht so wirklich groß du hast du hast im
enterprise umfeld esx und workstation im kleinen umfeld dann hast du dings wie
heißt der kram wie heißt der kram auf mac parallels oder so halt nee fusion
fusion heißt das auf mac ne, fusion
ja google sagt viel wenn der tag lang ist, google gehört, docker gehört aber
nicht google und der hersteller der das gekauft hat hat keine ahnung zwei drei
wochen nachdem das rausgekommen ist gesagt dass swarm keine neuen
erweiterung mehr bekommt ach jetzt hat der bot kapiert, ich kann dir das
raussuchen hier warte mal, docker swarm dead, is docker swarm end of life
blablabla das ist schwachsinn das ist viel zu alt
future of docker swarm is docker swarm, was ist das für eine komische seite
von ks
swarm ist dead, ist alles zu alt das war nach der übernahme wer hat ein docker
wer hat ein docker gekauft also wir haben das verkauft an mirantis swarm
man muss muss man mal gucken
ja ja blablabla
das liest sich jetzt wie eine 180 grad wende von dem was am anfang erzählt
wurde kein schimmer
okay sie sagen sie entwickelts doch weiter nachdem es am anfang erst hieß
doch nicht aber wann kam die letzte version raus das ist doch alles auf
sparflamme oder kann auch keiner erzählen aber es macht auch keinen sinn ganz
ehrlich kubernetes ist das ding was gewonnen hat es ist doch vielleicht ein
bisschen doof für kleinere sachen aber letztendlich kubernetes knowledge ist
das was man braucht bot kaputt ja anscheinend ist der bot gerade im arsch
matrix sein schiff für den sub
so kurz ganz klar aber nicht klausen das brauchen wir jetzt also was wir heute
machen ist folgendes ich ich zeige euch das noch war wir haben uns das letztens
angeschaut letztens letztens ist gut gestern es gab es gab vor ein paar tagen
eine telekom störung heute wieder ip leak wahrscheinlich es gab von ein paar
tagen in störung bei der telekom für die die telekom ich fasse das jetzt noch
mal schnell zusammen für die die telekom eigentlich nichts
kann konnte und was passiert ist es folgendes ich versuche es mal ganz kurz
zusammenzufassen ein bulgarischer provider wir machen das nicht mit
raspberry pi wir machen das mit mit packet tracer da kann man auch besser
zugucken also ein bulgarischer provider also nur nur ganz kurz ein bulgarischer
provider hat behauptet er würde die netze von der telekom bereitstellen und
die router oder die router bei microsoft haben ihm das geklaubt und
dementsprechend sind die ganzen pakete die zu irgendwelchen dsl anschlüssen
gehen sollten nie angekommen weil die wurden zum bulgarischen provider
geschickt in der bulgarischen provider konnte natürlich damit nichts anfangen
ob das jetzt hijacking absichtlich war oder ob sich einer vertippt hat man
weiß es nicht so und was man dazu wissen muss und wovon ich keine ahnung habe ich
möchte das hier noch mal durch ich habe keine ahnung davon ich habe das gerade
mit cisco sachen noch nie im leben gemacht dass wir testen heute was kann
aus einem nicht funktioniert ja was man wissen muss ist dass provider sich über
bgp austauschen das ist ein routing protokoll wo man dann quasi ja in die
welt rausposaunen kann welche netze man anbietet besser es ist eigentlich ist ein
bisschen komplizierter also man hat eine id jeder provider kriegt eine id und mit
dieser id kann man dann mehrere prefixes advertisen oder annunzen
prefixes sind quasi ip netze so und wenn das andere router bekommen dann tragen
jetzt pass ich in der routing tabelle ein oder entscheiden sich eventuell das
dort hin zu schicken oder natürlich dumm wenn das telekom netz auf einmal
bei einem bulgarischen providers stripes ja das ist eine gute frage was
könnte man da als heute heute nehmen
hier basteln kannst kannst sagen wir basteln bgp im packet tracer oder
irgendwie sowas so und es ist wie gesagt doof wenn eben ein bulgarischer
provider sagt es hat telekom netze und deswegen ging das ganze kaputt und das
will ich mal nachbauen weil ich habe davon keine ahnung und mich interessiert
wie einfach das ist und was man dazu machen muss bgp zu konfigurieren deswegen
was wir zwar machen ich gucke mal ob das ganze in der windows 11 funktioniert wir
missbrauchen hier mal wieder die windows 11 vm für dinger wofür ich sie eigentlich
nie angelegt habe wir könnten auch die cute vm nehmen da haben wir nämlich schon
da haben wir nämlich schon nur bunto dafür aber wir nehmen mal welche
windows windows 11 vm ist eigentlich die richtige die hier glaube was achso
verklickt bgp hat null authentication ja man kann das ganze wohl irgendwie
signieren habe ich gelesen und was man machen kann ist wohl außerhalb von bgp
man kann wohl noch irgendwie was rein skripten dass man im hintergrund
nachguckt ok auf wen ist dann überhaupt dieses netz registriert und wenn das
nicht übereinstimmt dann lehnt man es ab
aber microsoft macht das anscheinend nicht wir basteln das heute überhaupt
nicht mit dem raspberry pi nach das stimmt überhaupt nicht was da steht
scherz wie bettet für bastel das heim mit cisco packet racer nach raspberry pi
kak wait einfach mit pering db api verifizieren was auch immer keine ahnung
aber das kann man sicherlich irgendwie machen ich habe gesagt ich habe da ich
sag es heute mal wirklich sonst sage ich das zwar auch aber heute sag ich noch
mal ganz ehrlich ich habe absolut keine ahnung davon wirklich nicht das ist nicht
mein gebiet wir müssen wir müssen erstmal windows windows updaten lassen es
geht aber schnell xbox app alda geste geste weg install jawoll
da soll er mal dotnet update installieren meinetwegen check vor
updates check mal vor updates email liegt oh nein nyx das ist eine das ist eine
10-minute mail adresse die es gar nicht mehr gibt aber wir können schon mal
packet racer nicht runter aber nicht mit edge alda und pin an pin by the way
warum geht warum geht denn das eigentlich nicht mehr warum muss man das jetzt
eigentlich starten und sagen pin warum kann man das nicht mehr tracken
droppen das ist richtig das ist richtig wird
schämt von microsoft oder ich finde es viel informat nicht informativer
intuitiver dass da rein zu tracken droppen also was wir jetzt brauchen ist
das da packet racer download genau track und drop ist bloat
so wir brauchen das hier das blöde ist dazu muss man sich passisco anmelden
dass man das verwenden kann also wir brauchen hier packet racer download so
was wir jetzt machen ist folgendes ich habe mir nämlich schon überlegt es
gibt einen cisco iot einen kostenlosen cisco iot kurs musst du nicht also ich
habe gesehen es gibt ein kostenloses iot kostenlosen man kann es auch anonymen
benutzen wie soll das funktionieren ja da musste wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
tricks machen ich kann es mir aber so gar nicht downloaden ich melde mich hier
einfach mit einer fake adresse an kein problem
ach geht das zumindest wir melden uns jetzt einfach mal für den cisco kurs
anfügen den fake cisco kurs mit einer fake email adresse easy und dann kann ich
packet racer auch runterladen so sign up today 10
minute mail erste mal adblock wir brauchen hier das internet adblock origin
wir benutzen das internet also braucht man jubelock ohne jubelock geht hier
nix jawoll hinzufügen
ist der ausfall dann wegen windows oder wegen den telekom routern
der ausfall ist weder wegen windows noch wegen den telekom routern der ausfall
ist wegen den routern bei microsoft
der bulgarische provider hat gesagt er hat jetzt netze von der telekom und die
microsoft also das war der erste fehler der zweite fehler dass die microsoft
router das einfach geschluckt haben oder das microsoft das einfach geschluckt
hat ohne das zu überprüfen da kann die telekom nichts führen
das kann auch nix für was für ein ausfall der hier den bauen wir heute nach
wird überprüft das wird denn da überprüft an muss man enter drücken
sonst geht es dann aber backt man sieht das popup nicht was hat es jetzt
installiert oder man käs warum ist mein chrome so brauchen
aber hat es aber installiert alles gut so 10 min mehr
wir müssen es erst mal pasisco anmelden restart
ok wenn aus wir wenn wenn du willst wenn aus wir restarten dich auch
typischer monach erst wenn aus moment hallo max kannst du mir helfen ich bin
technisch komplett ein noob meine frage ist es ein großer verlust wenn ich über
meine playstation 5 60 herzbildschirm holen weil die playstation naja ist es
e fraglich wie viel spiele auf der playstation 5 wirklich mit 120 fps laufen
oder beziehungsweise 120 herz auch irgendwie sind sinnvoll nutzen können
naja ob es ein großer verlust ist kann ich dir nicht sagen ich kann nicht in die
zukunft gucken wie viele 120 fps spiele es geben wird und wenn du jemand bist
der empfänglich dafür ist ja also der den unterschied da gut spürt also ich
merke den ich merke unterschied sofort zwischen 60 120 mit dem controller ist
vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger würde ich schon sagen also wenn ich mir
einen neuen bildschirm kaufen würde dann wahrscheinlich auch ein mit 120 aber
wenn ich einen habe schon der nur 60 kann kann das mal weg hier dann würde ich
mir keinen neuen kaufen dafür
singler dankeschön für den primes ab
oder du holst dir einen gaming monitor da kannst du den nämlich auch gleich am
rechner verwenden ob es ein fernseher gibt 120 fps unter 1000 euro ne aber gut
ein guter fernseher kostet aber glaube ich also wenn du einen guten fernseher
willst auch was mit backlight dimming und hdr unterstützung und sagen wir mal 55
zoll plus da kommst du eigentlich für den gescheiten fernseher nicht 100.000
euro rum oder man holt sich halt einen gaming monitor das ist eh die bessere
variante aber da ist halt kleiner
aber man kann ihn auch am pc verwenden wie gesagt ich habe seit einem jahr jetzt
ungefähr einen 240 herz monitor und das ist richtig pock auch wenn die farben
jetzt nicht das allergeilste sind passt das so im telekom ausfüllen ja ja genau
das machen wir ich weiß was das teams chat ist das etwa der cute chat
eingebaut direkt den windows continue was passiert jetzt der leht im
hintergrund teams runter ich werde mit euch der leht im hintergrund teams runter
und macht dinger monka es war was passiert
tatsächlich erst erst mal teams runter geladen ja wunderbar
großes großes kino microsoft ok 10 minute mail also hier beste beste
email adresse genau die brauche ich die brauche ich ich brauche noch 10 minuten
wieder beste email adresse so als wenn man spazisco mann sein abtoday upload to
me today send me a file mega upload irgendwie erinnert mich das da dran
mega so ne hier firstname max lastname forger's
so germany machen wir mal falls die ip adressen checken ich bin certified über
13 ich komme aus lower saxony 2 plus 5 kritisch create account ich hoffe die
haben das nicht geplugged mit 10 minute mail im früher 2020 kommt der
nachfolger echt der hat der hat auch mega gegründet und hat es dann an die
china chinesischen china chinesen aus china verkauft jackson smith alles klar
jackson smith hat uns eingeladen leute ich hoffe ich hoffe ihr seid auch so
begeistert dass wir jetzt bei mit jackson smith diesen iot kurs machen
ich so 10-minute mail deiter hier welcome
enter your password ok
create my account muss mir aufschreiben big brain password
der war dieses rumgeboschte da ok birthdate ja ach so moment moment wir sind ja älter
als 13 hier da perfekt haben wir sind für disabled sage ich nicht ich habe ich habe
keine ahnung und jeb alter triggert allein schon die frage ich ich prefer not to say
so complete profile alles klar nein ich will in kors nicht lauschen ich will mit dem kors
überhaupt nichts zu tun haben download packet tracer auf geht's packet tracer für windows
im moment ist die alte version warum latsch die alte version runter mit schwachsinn ich hoffe das
sieht noch so aus wie das programm was ich kenne ich habe das früher früher gerade in
der ausbildung total oft verwendet ich habe keine ahnung ob das noch so aussieht packet
tracer war richtig nice früher was die sysco schulung während unserer schulausbildung war
so absturz warum monka stier hatte der typ keine ahnung oder was oder hast du was nicht deins für
deine test kannst du auch gehen es drei das könnte ich schon machen aber gerade bei gehen es drei
braucht man doch originale originale bios und firmware sachen für die für die routers if ng
kenne ich nicht packet tracer ist als richtig nice mit dem step für step simulator und sowas
weiß ich nicht wie einfach das in der anderen ist egal soll installieren wir den kram jetzt
der lehrer hat keine ahnung ok ja jetzt next jawoll 8.01 das heißt jetzt erst rausgekommen
das ist super pleading pleading edge high technology five head software also das einzige
was ich bei sysco also was ich je mit sysco am hut hat ist ich habe mal einen cc na gemacht
vor zehn jahren elf jahren zwölf jahren vor zwölf nee doch ungefähr nee doch ja ungefähr vor
zwölf jahren habe ich man cc na gemacht aber ansonsten habe ich keine ahnung das einzige
legit das einzige was ich noch weiß von sysco routern ist dass man nach dem einloggen en schreiben
muss das ist alles ich habe keine ahnung mehr ovel lucas ja mir auch gemacht was die am cc
na benotet für den unterricht okay das ist schon fail der andere seit ich muss sagen
ct na ist auch nicht sonderlich schwer ok also sysco package racer package racer would you
like to run multi-user wenn applika was das für eine bescheuerte frage was soll das überhaupt
bedeuten would you like to run multi-user when application starts was was was soll mir das
ja yes no was sagt mir das no was möchte es mir was möchte es mir mitteilen hat irgendjemand
plan no no ich mache einfach no so ja ja allo alles gut wach ok net net academy login was war
meine ten minute mail nochmal ich brauche noch zehn minuten länger alles klar email
next habe ich extra aufgeschrieben ich habe das eben gerade eingetippt
äh what the fuck
wollen die mich verarschen tsche tsche tsche tsche tsche tsche tsche tsche tsche tsche
forgot password oder habe ich mich ver via email jawohl email send ok sysco password
reset was ist das da unten am ging das weg geh weg winnows reset password ich copy paste
jetzt einfach nur noch dann kann nix falsch kann ich schiefgehen
hi peta agile alles klar so jetzt aber ok keine ahnung was auch immer
brauchst du eigentlich noch das copy paste history tool äh welches welches copy paste
history tool ach so ja ja ja ja das verwende ich doch aber das ist winnows ich sollte übrigens
clipboard ausschalten clip clipboard settings sonst sonst zeige ich euch jetzt sonst schon
schaue ich euch jetzt mein password wie macht man das aus jemand eine ahnung wie mache ich
das aus clipboard ja ach clipboard history ist schon oft ok es ist die fall aus ok wir
sind eingeloggt also das heißt wir können wir können uns jetzt daran austoben excellent
ok ok ich bin begeistert es sieht im prinzip noch genauso hässlich aus wie früher ich
muss aber ehrlich sagen früher sah das schöner aus das sieht jetzt nicht besser aus es sieht
hässlicher aus als früher guckt man guckt man den alten packet tracer an wartet mal
machen wir kurz die liegungsgesellschaft der alte der alte packet tracer in gelb der war
der war viel der war viel hübscher ja gelb früher kennst du das noch aus der berufsstelle
ja ja unter anderem packet tracer 6 jetzt genau genau packet tracer 6 ja so sah das
früher aus jetzt immer ohne mist das sieht auch besser aus als das neue oder das sieht
zwar oldschooliger aus aber sieht besser aus das da versus das da das sieht so klein und
unübersichtlich aus jetzt alles so wisst ihr was wir machen wir machen den boomer modus
scale make text size bigger machen wir jetzt text size falls es überhaupt frisst muss
man da jetzt neu starten für wisst ihr ob man als neu starten muss für kannst du das
nicht im programm umstellen keine ahnung ich habe das seit zwölf jahren das erste mal
wieder offen nein das interessiert das nicht also ich muss die gar ein bisschen größer
machen sonst ist mir das zu boomer style ich preferences und size hier bm wie das passt
es noch nicht mal daneben an ist ein bisschen brauchen kann kann es sein dass ein bisschen
prognos ok jetzt hat man die chance was zu erkennen jetzt habe ich die chance dass man
was sieht cli man auch ein bisschen größer das ist eigentlich die java anwendung leute
wollen wir wetten dass es eine java anwendung ist ich wette auf gifts ab dass es eine java
anwendung ist ok also mal gucken ob der kram noch so funktioniert wie früher also wir track
und droppen network devices pc end devices pc pc die verbinden wir mit einem switch ich
teste erst mal nur ob der kram noch so funktioniert wie früher java fx oder swing wahrscheinlich
java fx aber keine ahnung das kann ich einschätzen so wir droppen den switch dahin und jetzt
müssen die verkabeln hatten die nicht früher noch die ports hier angezeigt hatte man nicht
früher noch ports angezeigt oder so so jetzt kann man das verbinden soll man glück haben
ich weiß nicht ob die links standardmäßig abgehen oder nicht link ist ab ist der link
hier auch ab ab ab ok passt der hat aber gesüngt der hat nur gesüngt mit 100 mbit na gut juckt
mich jetzt nicht so und jetzt kommen wir also das ist quasi ein simulator für netzwerkgeräte
ja so desktop jetzt wir tun jetzt einfach mal so als ist das hier ein echter pc interface
static wir machen irgendwas was man kennt 12168 0.1 so weiß ich ob man nach speichern
verdrücken muss kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern 12168.0.2 muss man da speichern
muss man irgendwie save drücken anscheinend nicht gut und jetzt gucken wir mal terminal
das funktioniert so nicht nicht terminal was braucht man command prompt ok ping 192.168.0.1
hey wir können den zu den pingen so und jetzt zeige ich euch mal was das coole an packet
tracer ist wenn ich finde man konnte den jetzt nämlich in den simulations modus stellen oder
in den step by step modus das war früher so ein knopf hier unten wo ist denn das da simulation
mode also was jetzt passiert das ist mega nice wenn man netzwerk grundlagen lernen
will also was mega nice ist simulation und jetzt kann ich mir quasi hier ist das hässlich
das neue ui meine güde das ist mega pains champ ich guck mal kann man vielleicht den
font hier noch ist ist ist das hier cli tooltips ist das gerade irgendwie größer geworden
ist das gerade irgendwie auf einschlag größer geworden so und jetzt kann man sich live anzeigen
lassen was netzwerk technisch passiert also ich gehe zum beispiel hier auf command prompt
sagt ping jetzt gucken wir mal zu ich mache ich mache den ping an und wir sehen hier hier
geht das erste package los und zwar das ist ein icmp package da kann man auch reingucken
da kann man sich richtig an anzeigen modell für die ganzen fisi fans da kann man sich
richtig anzahlen ok wie sieht das wie sieht das paket aus also wir sehen layer 1 ist ethernet
dann ist layer 2 ist der ethernet header den kann man übrigens auch irgendwie angucken
lassen ja genau guckt euch das mal an man kann sich sogar anzeigen lassen wie die einzelnen
headers aus ausgefüllt sind das ist richtig nice so dann sieht man layer 3 source ip quell
ip und hier hast du den ethernet frame wie das aufgebaut ist du hast den ip header und
du hast das was in icmp drin steht das sind richtige 5 hat leute ich das ausgedacht haben
so und was ich jetzt mal mache ist dass ihr mal seht das können wir an der stelle ich
speichere das mal save desktop hack wait ich weiß nämlich nicht wie ich abcache cleare
und sowas doch ich habe vorher schon gepinkt das mit dem ab package will ich nämlich zeigen
ich starte das jetzt einfach mal neu und dann zeige ich euch mal was eigentlich passiert
wenn man ein netzwerk request macht und ein rechner zum anderen rechner pinkt recent files
also config desktop command prompt simulation ok und was normalerweise passiert ist dieser
rechner da also der hat die ip01 hinten und der hat die 02 umgedreht der hat die 01 und
der hat die 02 hinten als ip so und der kann normalerweise gar kein package schicken von
da an da zum pingen das geht nicht warum geht das nicht weil der rechner nicht die mac adresse
von dem rechner hat wir machen ja nicht ip wir machen auch nicht icmp wir machen unten
drunter ethernet und dafür brauchst du die mac adresse von deinem anderen rechner den
du anpingen willst das heißt das muss man vorher erfragen so ich mache das jetzt noch
mal ping 192 168 0.1 so jetzt sieht man schöner so jetzt versucht er einen ping package zu
schicken so aber der kann das package nicht schicken weil er die mac adresse nicht weiß
also ihr seht er versucht hier das zusammen zu bauen aber layer 1 layer 2 empfehlen ihm
die informationen für also was macht er also der versucht einen ping zu schicken von
pc von pc 1 an pc 0 kann es aber nicht weil ihm die mac adresse fehlt also nächster schritt
ist ein uprequest machen uprequest habt ihr bei dem tcp dam angeschmissen habt so vielleicht
schon mal gesehen versucht ein uprequest zu machen und da kann man jetzt auch reingucken
in so einen uprequest wie das ganze aussieht und er fragt im prinzip nur das ist hier broadcast
der fragt broadcast sagt mal wer hat denn die ip 192 168 0.1 das steht da drinnen wenn
ich das genau angucken will man sieht das hier anhand von von protocol type was da was das
ist ja also passt der fragt jetzt ins netzwerk rein also wer hat denn diese ip wenn da mehrere
rechner dran hängen würden würden das jetzt alle bekommen so nächster step so nächster
step ab geht an switch das stimmt nicht so das stimmt nicht so was soll mir das jetzt
sagen achso das ist nicht der empfänger ok ja das ist klar weil der switch soll das eigentlich
nur durchreichen kann es sein dass der link noch nicht oben ist spanning tree kann es
sein dass der link noch nicht oben ist was zum geil macht er jetzt mit spanning tree
what is happening ok nochmal ok nochmal package was was bin ich sehend was passiert was passiert
ok noch ein package geht das jetzt vielleicht endlich mal ah jetzt kommt der ab durch ok
der irgendwie waren die ports noch nicht richtig oben keine ahnung so und seht ihr jetzt antwortet
der der rechner hat jetzt geantwortet mit mit einer antwort und zwar sagt er jetzt hey
meine meine mac adresse passen zu der ip adresse so und wenn das angekommen ist an dem rechner
dann kann der wiederum den ping los schicken und dann geht der ping auch zurück und dann
kommt die antwort so funktioniert das genau der port war vorher nicht richtig oben keine
ahnung was da was da was da abgeht ja das wird genau der link war noch nicht richtig
oben vom switch mukka mukka vier alles klar dankeschön für den primes ab exzellent so
so funktioniert packet tracer und jetzt kommen das ist wie zauberei also das ist wirklich
das beste tool finde ich zum lernen was auf netzwerkebene funktioniert das ist wirklich
nice so und jetzt widmen wir uns bei der telekom geschichte du solltest spanning tree port
fast auf den pc ports aufdrehen alles klar weiß ich natürlich wie die passenden komando
zeilen befehle dafür sind auf dem sysco switch logisch wer weiß das aus dem kopf nicht
also heise bgp hijacking so und was wir jetzt versuchen nachzustellen ist folgendes wohlgemerkt
ich habe keine ahnung davon ich kann zwar netzwerk basics ja und ich kann dir auch erklären
wie das in einem eigenen netz ip technisch so funktioniert kein problem ja aber bei sowas
habe ich noch nie gemacht habe ich absolut kein plan von also wir versuchen jetzt mal
nachzubauen was die telekom beziehungsweise stimmt nicht was die telekom was die telekom
macht und was microsoft gemacht hat und was der bulgarische provider gemacht hat wir lassen
den bulgarischen provider erst mal weg wir machen mal den bild wir machen wirklich mal
die billigste die billigste packet racer kann kein bgp doch doch doch das konnte das konnte
der glaube ich schon früher ich glaube packet racer kann bgp relativ relativ sicher werden
aber gleich sehen probieren probieren klein mal aus ob das funktioniert wir suchen einfach
mal danach ob packet wenn packet racer kein bgp kann wer durft aber ich ich bin mir relativ
sicher dass es dass es das kann packet racer labs bgp konfiguration ja wenn es den lab
für packet racer gibt dann kann es kann es bgp bgp hört sich fast an wie irgendein
gesetzbuch bürgerliches gesetzbuch so also das versuchen wir nachzubauen wir lassen
erst mal den bulgarischen provider weg ich muss erst mal versuchen ob ich in irgendeiner
Art und Weise in der Lage bin per bgp netze ich glaube das nennt sich prefixes da auszutauschen
nie gemacht absolut null plan davon so ich versuche das mal so nachzubauen wie ich mir
das so als kack noob denken würde so ich speicher das jetzt mal als tech telekom also weg delete
so die pc ist die pc ist die pc was sind das jetzt ja delete delete alles weg also
ich mache ich mache ich mache das jetzt mal so wie ich mir das als kack noob vorstellen
will da das bin ich kann man das rename kann man kann man diese dinger da irgendwie renamen
hier display name das bin das ist der chat das ist der chat leute das seid ihr oder wir
nennen das anders das ist dsl kunde wir nennen es mal so wie es wie es theoretisch ist so
also das ist der dsl der rechner vom dsl kunde so dann brauchen wir die telekom die hatten
die hatten einen router fuck welchen router nehme ich denn dafür jetzt ich habe 2881
ist ein bill ist ist ist ein schlechter alter crap router oder ich weiß ich aus dem kopf
nicht ich nehme jetzt einfach den so das ist die telekom und da muss man auch mal das
ding ist richtig krank da muss man da muss man glasfaser module einlegen und so was das
man theoretisch dass man simulieren kann gibt schon gibt schon ein fertiger router irgendwas
was ich einfach einfach so verwenden kann gigabit alter meine gut ich brauche ich brauche
einfach in den router pt was ist ein pt es gibt vorlagen wo denn was ist denn ein pt router
pt ist so packet tracer oder was quasi so ein minimal ding für packet tracer der kann
aber bestimmt kein bgp der probieren wir mal aus would you like to enter the initial configuration
dialogue no wir machen das ist alles von hand lul en das ist das einzige was ich weiß für
sysco router konfigurieren en sonst kann ich nix ich erinnere mich ich erinnere mich konfte
wie konnte man hier noch mal abbrechen es kämpft und das weiß ich nicht mehr wie konnte
man das noch mal abbrechen weiß das jemand ne ne ne kontrol kontrol f6 ne ne ne kontrol
f6 ist ja ich machs machs zu kontrol x ich weiß was wir machen wir rebooten den einfach
lul da fängt es ja bei mir schon an kontrol f6 kontrol c nein nein da bricht nix ab ok
sysco cancel dns ah ok er hat es er hat es er hat es gecheckt er hat es er hat es gecheckt
also konfte da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern bgp ne ok jetzt müssen wir suchen
es kann sein dass dieser router das nicht kann bgp konfig sysco jetzt wirds ach du scheiße
show show bgp ok geht das geht das so show moment es war fragezeichen war er verfolgt
ne sh ist show stimmts ne ne fragezeichen ne exit ich kann das überhaupt nicht mehr
ich bin total unfähig show geht in konfig nicht wie komm ich in modus zurück noch
mal en ne show bgp ok der kann das nicht der router ok da müssen wir einen anderen ausprobieren
haben wir so ein vor langen während stande mich mit pail new fallen und da kann man diverse
vorlagen aus für was ne ok wir speichern das mal yes nö da macht er einfach so neu
wir lernen das jetzt noch cli en show bgp das mach ich falsch oder open samples open
samples yes ihr meint schon das da ne gibt es gibt es bgp samples gut dann gucken wir
wir sind einfach mal super faul wir gehen einfach mal hier ich hatte noch eben ein video
ich hatte noch eben ein video sysco bgp package tracer da gab es noch ein video zu lab how
to configure bgp package tracer also zeig her router 1841 hat er 1841 ja es braucht
verschiedene module für anschlüsse alles klar interessiert mich nett jaja aus die
konfig au label sollte ich das ding das wäre tatsächlich sinnvoll ja ja alles klar alles
klar alles klar ok ok achtung big brain time zeig her wie das funktioniert
moment wo macht er das im konfig modus sagt der router bgp das probiere ich jetzt mal aus
ob das überhaupt damit theoretisch funktionieren würde cli also en oh nein ich habe hilfe
ich gehe fort reboot reboot reboot war er im konf war er im konf drinnen konfig muss
er noch anmachen ok so no no no yes en also und jetzt root router ok man das geht das
geht damit das geht doch damit alles klar kann ich jetzt auch aber jetzt kann jetzt
kann ich auch show also keine ahnung ich habe so keinen plan was ich da mache ok aber
das also man kann es zumindest schon mal konfigurieren alles klar hat max nicht mal physik gelern doch
doch wir machen erst mal das cli font noch ein bisschen fetter rauder der router font
muss dicker cli 15 dass man aber es erkennt also ich bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher was sie
unter 15 verstehen 16 ich weiß jetzt nicht genau was größer geworden ist aber ist das
in irgendeiner art und weiß jetzt größer geworden also wunderbar wunderbar ok ok so
wir machen das jetzt wir machen das jetzt auch big brain technisch wie dieser typ also
wir nehmen den router von der telekom das ist jetzt mal stellvertretend für die gesamte
telekom ja dann nehmen wir den den von microsoft und dann nehmen wir den server wo wir hin
wollen so alles klar so wir benennen das wir benennen den kram jetzt mal wie hat er wie
hat er tut das eben mit labels gemacht das fand ich äußerst nice wie geht wie geht
das mit labels zeig mir label label hier was ist das da ist neben so ein knopf das gibt
den gibt es nicht mehr den gibt es nicht mehr den knopf der ist outdated ok das so das ist
das ist microsoft microsoft azure router oder egal der microsoft router file fat heißt
der intern das ist der microsoft router wie kriegt man als labels hin set background image
cluster what the fuck labels oben zweite reihe draw line draw rectangle das ist halt als
simple pdu ich weiß nicht was ich jetzt gemacht habe ich will note ach das ist eine note ich
habe gar man kann die geräte irgendwie labelen oder so was ist denn das ich keine ahnung
egal ich mache jetzt ich mache jetzt eine note note dran dass ich dass ich mir das merken
kann was was ist also ja gut brauche ich ja nicht habe ich habe ich ja schon dran stehen
die ip schreibe dann unten drunter dran so und das ist da das ist dann der telekom router
na config telekom router die hat die telekom hat natürlich nur ein router ist ja logisch
also braucht ihr auch mehr sondern der hat intern heißt ja ja ja ok wunderbar so jetzt
können wir den ganzen jetzt können wir den ganzen ganzen krampf verbinden lautet also
können wir jetzt verbinden wir verbinden einmal unseren unseren pc von daheim wir wir
scheißen einfach mal drauf dass er noch einen dsl modem dazwischen ist und du garantiert
nicht auf diesem router rauskommst der auch irgendwelche bgp sachen etwa heißt announced
aber das egal so ruta ports gehen standardmäßig nicht ab da muss ich erst sagen port port
ab oder so ich meine ich kann auch noch einen switch dazwischen hängen wenn das irgendwie
zu voll ist dann dann verbinden wir den router mit dem mit dem mit dem microsoft router warum
ist das jetzt serial warum ist das eine serielle verbindung das ist es sicherlich oder ist
es glasfaser was ist denn was ist denn serial ok wir machen das jetzt mal stellvertretend
für für glasfaser stellen wir können natürlich noch ein paar glasfaserkarten rein haben wir
doch hier oder wir haben doch hier glasfaser stells drin ist ffe ffe ist auch ist auch
glasfaser connection oder wir haben kupfer wir haben eine serial und wir haben glasfaser
stells ok ne ne ne das wollen wir nicht weg weg damit nein ich will den telekom telekom
router nicht löschen wie löscht ihr ok ok gut ich brauche verbindung so ich brauche
fiber jawoll fiber connected an das da das sieht nach fiber aus hoffe ich mal das sieht
für mich vom anschluss her ebenso aus als wäre das irgendwie glasfaser zeug so ok das
ist ein telekom router der geht zum microsoft und microsoft geht dann ganz normal wieder
zu ihrem server alles klar wunderbar ok ja 100 mbit fiber das ist doch zum testen egal
wer interessiert das denn ob das 100 mbit ist oder nicht so das ist die der billigste
aufbau der mir so einfällt in wirklichkeit kommt ja dann noch ein bulgarischer router
dazu da kommt er dann hier noch dabei der kommt dann aber später wenn der kram erstmal
von ja gute mahr gute switch switch of overrated ok bulgarischer provider und der router heißt
pains champ so das ist der der dann später böse dinger macht ok jetzt versuchen wir
das in irgendeine art und weise mal zum laufen zu bekommen ich habe absolut kein schimmer
wir machen das übrigens mit privaten netzen wobei warum eigentlich ok wir machen das wir
machen das jetzt mal kurz mit mit irgendwelchen netzen die ich aus dem kopf zusammen kriege
also 100 mbit poggers also wir machen jetzt mal hier eigentlich keine ahnung 10 kommen
wir bei 10 0 na komm nee 12216 168 0 punkt oder machen wir 1.1 ist das das ist das ist
der dsl kunde das natürlich das netz was die telekom garantiert nicht verwendet hier
ist auch noch gateway und so ein krempel setzen so und dann haben wir noch aesthetic ip address
1211 2.2 ist das so kann man sich gut merken so und jetzt und jetzt kommt jetzt kommt router
config die porch sind ja noch nicht ab mal gucken ob ich das noch irgendwie aus dem kopf
hin hin bekomme ich ich fürchte ich fürchte nicht also erst mal enable so en ist schon
ab irgendwie ab musste man sagen ab ach du weißt du weißt du heute nicht mehr so ein
port auf fährt enable ab wie ging das noch mal port das ist schon so lang her alter ok
das muss ich nachgucken cisco port config no shutdown nicht ab du musst es nicht absagen
du musst es no shutdown sagen genau das war der big brain cisco trick du hast du hast
ja nicht gesagt port hochfahren du hast ja gesagt no shutdown genau das war es so interface
interface so fast es ernet wir sind verbunden an wir sind verbunden hallo an die hier zeigt
dir das an wir sind verbunden an ok wo sind wir überhaupt verbunden 00 fa 00 0 slash 0
so ging das genau genau so war das so war das und jetzt muss man sagen ip kann das sein
ip address so und das war doch jetzt moment das das war doch jetzt cisco big brain notation
oder musste man das nicht umgedreht schreiben bei cisco irgendwie hat man da nicht subnet
maske hingeschrieben sondern hat man da nicht subnet maske umgedreht hingeschrieben also
0.0 255 also ip adresse also das hier ist der rechner 192 168 11 also kriegt der router
von uns 192 168 1.254 ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher ob was cisco best practice war die
letzte ip im netz oder die erste ip im netz was war da nochmal cisco best practice letzte
oder die erste ip im netz kein schimmer mehr kann man slash 24 machen geht das nein immer
die erste das ist jetzt vorbei so ip subnet maske 255 0 gut wunderbar und jetzt kann ich
sagen no shutdown bäum und jetzt der port oben in your face so und was ich jetzt machen
kann ist jetzt kann ich meinen router pingen command prompt ping 192 188 das bin ich selbst
und jetzt kann ich meinen router bringen ping 254 hey leute guck mal hier die verbindung
von pc zu router funktioniert schon mal konnte man nicht auch noch protokolle ausschalten
man konnte doch die ganzen unsinnigen protokolle ausschalten genau brauche man nicht bgp lassen
mal an rip usb end point das kann ich alles eingeschalten lassen das will ich nicht ich
will hier die dtp ausschalten und und und cdp und den ganzen ganzen crap da so er sollte
jetzt eigentlich pingen oder ist das schon fertig pingen also das haben wir schon mal
richtig gemacht verbindung zwischen zwischen telekom router und dsl kunde steht nicht dass
es in irgendeiner art und weiß was mit der realität zu tun hätte aber für meine netzwerk
skills reicht mir das erste mal normalerweise also realistisch betrachtet wäre das eigentlich
so wir hätten hier eine ordentliche anzahl an telekom routern die untereinander wahrscheinlich
über usbf weiß ich nicht verbunden wären und irgendwo hättest du dann hier einen edge
router der und also einen von vielen wahrscheinlich der das dann announced zu microsoft und dann
auch irgendwo hier was wurde also du hängst du hängst nicht an diesem backbone router
der auch bgp rausschickt als dsl kunde wird mich zumindest äußerst wundern das wäre
realistischer deswegen gibt es ja diese diese geschichte bei bgp mit autonomen system quasi
du hast ja 100 router von der telekom das interessiert dich aber von außen nicht wie die das intern
machen meint ihr wirklich die telekom hat nur einen router meint ihr zwei war nicht
drin oder wie einen sehr großen so und jetzt jetzt jetzt müssen wir irgendwie jetzt jetzt
hört bei mir auf ich konfiguriere jetzt noch mal den microsoft router das kriege ich nämlich
auch noch gebacken das muss ich zu machen kann ich auch zu machen telekom router das
ist übrigens der grund warum ich diesen scheiß nicht mag mit diesen fenstern ich
will einfach das nebeneinander haben so siehe leih ent konft interface fast as a net wo sind
wir hier verbunden auch 00 wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich 00 denke ich mal 0 slash 0 ip
address 1216 2222 255 255 0 no shut down alles klar so unsere port sind ab wir machen mal
den den üblichen ping test ob das ganze funktioniert 1216 22254 so wir können unseren router ping
jetzt müssen wir noch was wichtiges machen dass es überhaupt funktionieren kann wir
müssen bei unseren surfern einstellen dass wir den router als gateway verwenden weil
ansonsten also aktuell pass ich kann es euch ja mal zeigen aktuell ist es ja so wenn ich
darin ping 1221 sagt 1.1 von hier dann ich war mal kurz simulation an dann funktioniert
das ja nicht weil er macht einen ping der macht einen ping und der stellt jetzt schon
fest hey das ist außerhalb von meinem lokalen netz und ich habe kein gateway gesetzt ich
habe keine ahnung was ich machen soll also das kann nicht funktionieren ok also gehen
wir mal in die config und sagen default gateway so der default gateway von diesem server 122168
2.254 so wenn ich das ganze jetzt noch mal mache command prompt das ganze noch mal mache
dann sollte es zumindest bis zum router gehen aber dann von dort nicht weiter es geht zum
router so der router gucken seine routing tabelle und stellt fest ich habe keine ahnung
was ich damit machen soll und schickt ihm eine fehlermeldung zurück gibt es nicht kann
man sogar reingucken in die fehler also was ist die fehlermeldung kann man reingucken
und man sieht dass es ein icmp typ 4 ist typ 8 wir gucken mal nach icmp type 8 ist ein echo
request kann sehen dass es ein echo request ist es müsste es müsste eigentlich eine fehlermeldung
sein es es geht von microsoft router zu server jetzt bescheuert
dass es eine fehlermeldung gibt das heißt ein entry for destination ip address wo er
will dann das haben das verstehe ich nicht bin ich bin ich zu low brain für aber man
sieht ja dass es nicht funktioniert weil der ping müsste normalerweise hier rüber gehen
und das macht er ja nicht da bin ich jetzt zu low brain für wir halten uns nicht mit
so einfachen sachen auf so jetzt und jetzt und jetzt kommt das und jetzt kommt das interessante
da hört es bei mir jetzt auf also jetzt muss ich hier dazwischen erstmal eine verbindung
herstellen und dann muss ich diesen beiden routern sagen über diese verbindung tauscht
routing informationen aus also die sollen ok ich muss ich muss anders anfangen also
so ein router hat ja eine tabelle das kann ich euch auch mal zeigen moment ich schaue
root nee äh weiß ich gar nicht wie man sich das anzeigen lässt ja show ip ah nee erstmal
en warum kein switch zwischen die router warum soll ich einen switch hin machen show ip
root so das ist die routing tabelle von diesem router der hat halt nicht allzu viel drinne
stehen aktuell nee das icmp parkiert ist jetzt weg der hat nicht allzu viel drinne stehen
das einzige was er in seiner routing tabelle kennt ist sein lokales interface mehr hat
er ja auch nicht so was man jetzt machen kann ist wir können eine verbindung herstellen
zwischen diesen und diesem router was ist es show table show nee ip es ist show root ziemlich
sicher oder so table ggp gibt es noch was extra an das so aber was wir jetzt machen
können ist wir können hier zwischen diesen beiden routern manuelle verbindung herstellen
und dann sagen die restlichen informationen die sie in ihrer routing tabelle stehen haben
sollen sie miteinander austauschen so dass ich keine tabelle von hand pflegen muss also
wenn man sowas von hand konfiguriert dann müsste man jetzt hier bei diesem router einstellen
hey es gibt noch netz 192 168 1 0 slash 24 und das erreichst du über interface fa 4
0 so und ihr könnt euch vorstellen wenn man mehr als zwei router hat wird schon eklig
sowas zu konfigurieren normalerweise wenn man das intern macht ist das kein ding dann
nimmt man sowas wie uspf oder früher ripp oder sowas aber provider übergreifen geht
das ganze per bgp habe ich noch nie gemacht so also jetzt stellen wir erstmal eine verbindung
her zwischen diesem router und diesem router das heißt wir brauchen jetzt ein interconnect
netz oder wie auch immer man das nennt dementsprechend denken wir uns jetzt mal ich habe das falsche
felt angeschaut das ist durchaus möglich ja so wir nehmen jetzt mal in den netz was
braucht man da was was ist ein netz wir brauchen jetzt mit zwei ip adressen slash 30 slash
30 klingt gut ich glaube slash slash 30 hat vier ips und davon zwei nutzbar ne wir machen
einfach wir machen einfach easy easy mode machen easy mode ip calc 192 ne wir machen jetzt
irgendwie was anderes 10.0.0.0 slash 30 bam wir machen 10.0.0.0 slash 30 ok man sieht
dieses netz hat ganze zwei nutzbare host wunderbar das verwenden wir das ist das netz unsere
wahl also dann konfigurieren wir jetzt mal den port f a 4 0 alles klar also wie war das
jetzt interface ne erst konf t wie komme ich überhaupt auf konf t wieder raus a control
z excellent oder end end jetzt lerne ich endlich wieder ein bisschen cisco kram ich werde es
nie auf der arbeit brauchen nie jetzt schon aber ist auf jeden fall nicht schlecht was
man wieder gemacht hat also wie war das jetzt jetzt interface f a kann man kann man auch
so machen f a 0 ne 4 slash 0 ah das geht auch ok also und das braucht jetzt ip adress 10.10.10.0
slash eins so mache ich denn hier 10.10.10.1 slash 30 kriegt das jetzt wir haben es ja
in unserem ip calculator eben gesehen die erste ip in dem netz die verfügbar ist es
eins und die letzte ip ist zwei das reicht für beide router genau aus genau das schreibe
ich in meine skill beschreibung rein advanced advanced cisco kenntnisse ok ip adress an
die slash 30 geht er nicht ich brauche einen moment wir sind wir sind faul wir sind faul
welches abnet mask brauchen wir 255 255 255 254 alles klar ich sag doch man muss einfach
nur wissen wo es steht und übrigens wenn ihr hier irgendwas falsch macht vergesst
gleich der ganze scheiß funktioniert nicht ok no shutdown so das interface ist hochgefahren
ähm wie kann man sich nochmal e n ne end auch hier z show ip inter war das interfaces
ne ähm wie kann ich mir den interface den den interface status von allen interfaces
anzahlen lassen interface was show ip interface brief genau ok genau da sehen wir wir haben
den interface kann man den interfaces namen geben oder heißen die immer fast ethernet
00 könnte ich das jetzt auch umbenennen zum beispiel in was weiß ich interconnect oder
so oder oder irgendwie big brain uplink ach so der chat der chat ist heute wieder richtig
moment also wirklich massive high iq das liegt aber auch einfach an den ganzen prime subs
ist so sonst wäre das wäre das nicht möglich konf t du meinst erst konf oder kann man sowas
direkt schreiben ne ne das geht nicht oder also die konf t so interface fa 4 slash 0 das
ist nämlich unser unser ähm ja wie nennt man sowas eigentlich in der in der provider
sprache so nen so nen das ist ja nicht direkt in peering peering ist ja kann man sich ja
wirklich eher so vorstellen man steckt ein kabel von einem kabel von einem router zum
anderen ähm deswegen damit verdient er der d6 unter anderem sein geld uplink uplink koppelnets
oh das ist richtig oldschool das mag ich koppelnets das finde ich nice ich nenne es aber uplink
uplink klingt mir irgendwie sympathisch aber koppelnets finde ich auch geil koppelnets
klingt so wie so 1850 da gab es das zwar noch nicht aber das das klingt klassisch ja
so und jetzt habe ich description ne erstmal so rein und jetzt description description
und da kann ich jetzt zum beispiel sagen uplink oder sowas so und jetzt gehe ich da raus
und sag show alp brief und sehe und wo sehe ich jetzt dass das wo sehe ich jetzt dass
ich das uplink genannt habe brauche ich nicht raus und wo sehe ich jetzt das da muss ich
wahrscheinlich nicht brief machen sondern was anderes äh wie lasse ich mir das jetzt
anzeigen was ich für eine description eingestellt habe
exclude include show int desk das gibt es habe ich immer ausprobiert das geht nicht
oder oder muss man da ip weglassen aber ohne ip bringt auch nix interfaces ich bin verwirrt
show int status gibt es nicht aber es ist ja nicht schlimm ich weiß ja was was ist ich
weiß ja was was ist wir suchen google jetzt einfach mal cisco show interface with description
aha solved show interface show interfaces description habe ich doch eben gemacht show
ach ach so man muss das so machen ok show interface ne she baited mich chat show interfaces
es gibt sie nicht ergeblich darf ich muss kann ich das hier machen da muss ein du davor
das ist aber es scheint schon bei so einfachen dingern show interfaces description kann
ich angeblich machen wenn ich das in du davor macht bringt auch nix oder das gibt es wahrscheinlich
hier nicht oder kann das sein weil man show konfig konnte man noch machen nee muss man
das hier machen die running konfig war das aber ich show run war das show run ich erinnere
mich dunkel an so dinger so wo ist mein interface guck das interface hat überhaupt das hat
eine description jetzt aber doof na gut wir halten zwar nicht mit so easy mit so easy
mode sachen auf also wir haben jetzt ein interface haben wir das auch hochgefahren also hinter
kam hat das eine history nee also eine history zum durchsuchen fa 0 interface so no shutdown
interface hochgefahren also interface zwischen diesen beiden rudern ist drinne show wie hier
muss ich jetzt raus von hier kann ich doch jetzt nicht einfach port status und sowas
an kann ich mir hier den port status anzeigen lassen oder die ip kann ich jetzt hier sagen
irgendwie show wie lasse ich mir von diesem interface jetzt den kram hier anzeigen aber
ich bin ja noch in dem interface drinne was du ne ne ne chat chat das das ergibt keinen
sinn was ihr mir hier erzählt das gibt es nicht da muss ich auch jetzt erstmal hier
wieder raus oder das geht aber aber auto vervollständigen tut er mir nix tatsächlich ok das ist doof
da kann er nicht auto komplizieren ach so ok das natürlich erstmal gewöhnungsbedürftige
ok also ip wir haben jetzt 10 10 10 10 punkt 1 alles klar gut das ist der telekom switch
der telekom router jetzt gehen wir zum microsoft router und machen das gleiche da auch mal
en konft interfaces fa wir brauchen das gleiche glaube ich hier fa 4 0 ip address 10 punkt
10 punkt 10 punkt 2 slash nein 255 255 255 252 ok gut ok so und jetzt habe ich no shutdown
so und ah guckt mal jetzt sind die ports auch grün und jetzt kann ich den einen router den
anderen router ping moment moment ping 10 punkt 10 punkt 10 punkt 1 80 prozent 80 prozent
alles klar ok das funktioniert also ich kann jetzt von dem router den router ping was eventuell
auch schon funktioniert weil die dinge relativ clever sind wenn ich pesh habe funktioniert
der ganze kram jetzt hier schon 1 2 1 6 ich hoffe ich hoffe aber mal nicht ok zum glück
zum glück funktioniert das nicht ich meine von der theorie her kann es nicht funktionieren
aber ich hätte den zugetraut dass die dinger besonders clever sind wenn was direkt connected
ist miteinander ok also wir haben wir haben alles eingerichtet und jetzt kommt und jetzt
kommt der komplizierte teil jetzt muss ich also der router kann mit dem router kommunizieren
der server kann mit seinem router kommunizieren man klein kann mit seinem router kommunizieren
und umgedreht also theoretisch ist jetzt alles da dass der server zum klein kommt der klein
zum server aber was ja natürlich noch nicht funktioniert ist der router hier kennt dieses
netz nicht und der router hier kennt dieses netz nicht das muss ich denen jetzt beibringen
das hier alles habe ich schon mal irgendwann wenigstens gemacht ab jetzt habe ich wirklich
keinen plan mach jetzt noch mal show ip root zum vergleich
genau aber das andere also der router hier kennt dieses netz nicht das heißt jetzt muss
ich irgendwie und jetzt habe ich keinen plan mehr jetzt muss ich mal versuchen ob ich
über bgp das hinkriege diesem router das netz zu gehen mitzuteilen und umgedreht dazu
brauche ich aber einen guide sonst sonst hört auf möchtest du nicht das subnetz zwischen
router ein wenig größer machen der bulgarische router kommt dann kommt dann hier bei microsoft
dran extra an extra interphase naja das mag für dich einfach sein ich habe das noch nie
gemacht so also jetzt jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken wie geht das ich habe ich habe ich
habe ich habe ein video gefunden auf youtube was es erklärt da muss ich mal kurz durch
durch skippen so mir gehts hier übrigens auch nicht darum dass der chat mir das alles
vorsagt das ist ja dann witzlos also ich muss da lass mich schon mal selbst ein bisschen
gucken sonst sind wir in fünf minuten fertig und es hat keiner von uns irgendwas verstanden
so ok was macht der dude hier das ist ganze das ganze bla bla bla juckt mich nicht ich
brauche eigentlich nur die kommandos also was macht der router bgp ok das ist die as
nummer das ist die as nummer das ist das wo die telekom 3302 oder irgendwie sowas hat
er die telekom die telekom hatte 3320 so rum nicht 3302 3320 wir benutzen eigene as nummern
geht mir nur zum ausbringen also wir brauchen jetzt eine as nummer und dann sagt man ihm
welche networks man advertisen will denke ich mal ok also wir gehen wir sind jetzt auf
dem wir gehen jetzt auf den telekom router root nee was war das jetzt router erstmal
konfig anmachen so router bgp as 69 ok und jetzt muss ich ihm sagen welche netzwerke
er ankündigen soll ok das bedeutet ich sagt kann man dem nicht standardmäßig sagen kündige
alle netzwerke an die du hast geht das so nach dem motto bgp all oder sowas dann wäre
das wahrscheinlich einfacher ok jetzt kann ich sagen network redistribute connect oh nee
nee hört mal auf das war eher so das war das war eigentlich eher so ein witz ich hab
nicht gedacht dass das geht ich mach das jetzt ich mach das jetzt mal von hand ok könnte
ich da einfach sagen redistribute ernsthaft oh das ist nice das ist wirklich oh das ist
cool ich könnte sogar sagen wenn ich meine sachen über ospf laufen hab redistribute
mal alle meine ospf routen oder wie ok das ist natürlich cool ich mein wahrscheinlich
ist es ein bisschen viel des guten wenn man nicht weiß was man macht das finde ich interessant
ok ich versuche jetzt noch mal kurz zu erklären was der unterschied ist zu einer statischen
routing tabelle also in der statischen routing tabelle müsste ich jetzt ja folgendes machen
da müsste ich diesem router den eintrag rein schreiben das ist das netz sekunde da müsste
ich in diesen router eintragen es gibt das netz 192 168 1.0 slash 24 und das findest
du hier über diese diese verbindung also über diesen gateway dann würde würde ich angeben
ok netz 192 168 1.0 slash 24 ist erreichbar über dieses interface also über den gateway
lass mal ip gucken über 10.10.10.1 also da müsste ich hier eine statische routing tabelle
machen dass der das findet mit routing protokoll ist das eigentlich viel praktischer da sage
ich auf dem router einfach nur noch hey teil mal deinen anderen routern die angeschlossen
sind mit welche netze du hast so also das machen wir jetzt auf dem telekom router auf
dem telekom router kann man jetzt sagen hey teile mal der welt mit dass du netzwerk network
ok wie geht das jetzt netzwerk 192 168 1.0 slash ne subnet mask brauchen wir da ne 255
255 255.0 advertisen willst hoffe das ergibt sinn an dem mask muss ich noch davor schreiben
mask so mal gucken ob das jetzt tut hat funktioniert sonst noch irgendwas ne das brauche ich nicht
weil das das gleiche netz ist also ich habe keine keine slash 30 an meinen interfaces
das habe ich schon in weißer voraussicht nicht gemacht
aha jetzt gehts weiter wo macht er das denn in der anleitung ip root das brauchen wir
sch ip root was sagt das ding da jetzt bei mir ip root ja gut da erkennt er doch nix
neues so und wie lässt er sich die config anzeigen show run section bgp oh das ist ja
richtig richtig big brain hier show run und dann was section oh ich kann keinen pipe machen
section bgp no synchronisation no muss ich da jetzt noch irgendwas einstellen oder reicht
es jetzt wenn ich es beim anderen router konfiguriere weil das machte ich mache das jetzt mal bis
zu dem punkt auf dem anderen router auch also der router soll ankündigen dass er dieses
netz kennt und der router soll ankündigungen ankündigen dass er dieses netz kennt also
ich habe schon wieder ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie die richtigen sonntags ist
ok also router bgp ah ne asnummer das eine war s69 dann ist das jetzt as420 und dann
muss ich jetzt die netze also network network und das war jetzt 121 68 2.0 slash ne mask
255 255 255 0 so gut jetzt gehen wir mal in den simulations modus ob wir jetzt irgendwelche
bgp geschichten sehen oder so wahrscheinlich noch nicht das ist der telekom router das
ist der microsoft router warum geht denn da immer wieder raus ist der server neighbor
und remote s ok da da hört es jetzt bei mir auf also wie war das andere hier show run
und dann section ok das das juckt dir nicht kann man sich irgendwie explizit den status
von bgp anzeigen lassen so was wie root wie show oder bgp ok da hat nichts bekommen bisher
alles klar wunderbar also das heißt was muss ich jetzt machen steht da noch irgendwas hier
in der config drin hier das das muss man noch machen neighbor neighbor oh jetzt wird jetzt
wird jetzt wird advanced 5 kopf ich was da trage ich jetzt das interface ein über das
ich advertising will oder so so so verstehe ich das ok ok also also also das ist ja der
wahnsinn in den network nehmen wollen es war es war nicht network es war damit ich damit
ich da reinkomme muss dann gut bgp genau ach so und jetzt ist das auto das ist ich bin
jetzt auf dem telekom router da war das as 69 show gibt es sowas wie meine güte so und
da muss ich ihm jetzt sagen ich will das andere konfigurieren oder was soll jetzt müsste
er mir sagen ob ich mit mache also ich sag jetzt neighbor neighbor so und da sage ich
ihm jetzt das sage ich ihm da jetzt das interface über das er das rausschickt oder das interface
von seiner gegenstelle also sage ich ihm da jetzt die ip die ip von seinem interface oder
die ip von der anderen seite da also die andere seite also 10 10 10 2 ok also probieren wir
es mal aus also sage ich jetzt neighbor ist 10.10.10.2 subnet mask brauchen wir nicht
remote s so und da sage ich ihm jetzt wahrscheinlich auch die remote as oder die eigene wahrscheinlich
die remote also 420 oder die das eigene as oder das remote as ich würde mal ich würde
mal sagen das remote as jetzt muss ja das remote as sein sonst würde der hier nicht
moment warum hat er das warum hat er einmal das gleiche drin stehen warum hat er einmal
das so einfach ist das ganze wohl doch nicht wie ich mir das gedacht habe ich habe keinen
plan neighbor remote as da muss da muss jetzt nachgucken remote as das brauche ich da brauche
ich die hilfe da brauche ich die hilfeseite für oh really remote as number remote as number
of a bgp neighbor das bedeutet 420 in dem fall ne das weiß ich doch gar nicht was der
andere für eine as nummer hat an der stelle oder ok ich mache das jetzt einfach mal passt
so ok das heißt ich gehe jetzt noch mal raus und sage hier backtion ok ok das sieht doch
das sieht doch schon mal ganz sinnvoll aus das sieht doch schon mal ganz sinnlich aus
der zeigt mir hier jetzt an dass er dass er das netz 1221 68 1.0 hier über diese verbindung
zwischen den routern schickt aber remote as fort ich habe keine ahnung was ich da mache
ich weiß es echt nicht muss ich dann also immer die gegenstelle nach den infos fragen
ne du schickst der gegenstelle die infos deswegen kam es ja zu dem ausfall irgendein bulgarischer
provider hat den routern bei microsoft geschickt er hätte jetzt die telekom netze also du
fragst die gegenstelle nicht du schickst es der gegenstelle ok jetzt sind wir wieder
beim microsoft router da war jetzt das gleiche nur umgedreht von t router ich kann es mir
langsam merken router bgp 420 neighbor jetzt die ip 10.10.10.1 hat der hier wenn ich jetzt
nicht ganz falsch liege der hat 10.10.1 so und jetzt remote as 69 neighbor ab ajajaj
scheint zu funktionieren leute monkaS ok ok show ip root funktioniert bgp hat sich routern
ausgetauscht also was jetzt passiert ist der router kennt das netz von dem von dem router
ohne dass ich sie von hand eintragen musste so und jetzt sollte das eigentlich auch funktionieren
dass ich vom server vom dsl kunde den server pingen kann testen wir das mal check abstimmung
gucken ob ihr meint ob das funktioniert also wir machen mal abstimmung geht ping von client
zu server antworten ja nein umfrage dauereine minute redictions eigentlich es ist gar keine
prediction das ist nur eine umfrage leute es gibt es gibt es gibt nichts zu gewinnen in dem fall es
gibt einfach nur umfrage ich hätte predictions machen sollte hätte soll ich noch eine prediction
machen da könnt ihr channel points wetten solche prediction machen kann man das irgendwie abbrechen
ok ich kann kann man ich meine prediction prediction
vorhersage starten also geht der ping vom client an server durch fragezeichen ergebnis ja gibt es
nein ja das kann man jetzt weg machen das ist outdated einreichungszeitraum 30 sekunden ok
jetzt könnt ihr jetzt jetzt könnt ihr channel points verwenden massive gambling hier
besser als irgendwelche slot streams oder sowas ach du scheiße wir hatten das hier
reingehauen also das verhältnis von 1 zu ja ist schon krass unterschiedlich also sollte
es jetzt nicht gehen da hat jemand richtig viel glück ok 73 prozent sagen ja also probieren
was aus dsl kunde pink server so ich bin jetzt 122 2 punkt hatten der server für eine ip hat
der server für eine ip 2.2 dsl kunde pink server meant simulation wir simulieren jetzt wie das wie
das pinkt also ping bem ping startet nächster schritt warte mal etwas jetzt kommen wir mal
ins pgp rang warum geht das jetzt nicht habe ich mich vertippt ich habe doch ich habe eine
default gateway eingestellt wo ist mein default gateway hin das hatte ich doch ihr wart auch
vorhin dabei wo ich das eingestellt habe ich habe das doch vorhin eingestellt ok es hat nicht
funktioniert 254 habe ich so beim server eingestellt ich habe so beim server eingestellt ja ihr habt
nicht damit gerechnet wie dumm ich bin gateways einzustellen wie bestätige ich das ganze jetzt
predictions ergebnis wählen geht der ping vom server vom klein an so aber nein er geht nicht
vorsage abschließend es gämt ging die prediction nicht um pgp pgp die prediction muss ich schon so
auslegen wie sie geschrieben war nämlich auf der ping geht so gucken wir mal ob der ping jetzt
funktioniert nachdem ich jetzt richtig gesetzt habe wir machen keine neue prediction es sei denn
ihr seid scharf darauf dass wenn das ihr noch mal channel points verlieren könnt wollt ihr noch
noch eine prediction machen jetzt will keiner mehr jetzt will keiner mehr also ja noch ok
prediction wir machen wieder die gleiche prediction versagen starten sag standen
spaz granade
der erste fehler haben wir aus jetzt all in all in leute hier seh schon wenn das leucht ich
pinge noch nicht macht euch keine ich will nur sicherstellen dass das ding den den gateway
auch gecheckt hat okay was haben wir jetzt okay
die andere umfrage ist weg aber das ist ziemlich sicher aber auch die meisten gesagt ja okay dann
pingen wir mal würde ich sagen simulation an ping dsl kunde pinged zu ups dsl kunde pinged zu
server okay ping startet erst mal machen wir einen abrequest das ergibt sinn warum machen
wir chat big brain warum machen wir jetzt ein abrequest wer weiß es was müssen wir noch in
erfahrung bringen warum können wir den ping nicht einfach verschicken wir brauchen nämlich
noch die meck vom vom router richtig wir brauchen dass die meck von diesem interface hier so also
abrequest geht zum router hin abrequest geht vom router zurück und jetzt können wir das package
das den ping los schicken weil ich jetzt weiß ok ich habe die ganzen infos dafür alles klar
next ping ping geht raus leute mal gucken was passiert mal gucken ob es weitergeht ping geht
zum microsoft router sieht schon mal sehr gut aussieht schon mal sehr gut aus ping geht von
microsoft router anserver sieht auch gut aus force champ und jetzt antwort antwort vom server
geht zurück an microsoft router geht zurück an telekom router und geht sogar dsl kunde
bam und die antwort ist da hat funktioniert funktioniert kukier häkchen poggers dazu kann
man nur sagen alles klar also prediction geht der ping vom klein zum server ergebnis ist ja
so muss das sein excellent ok mein erstes bgp netz was ich jemals aufgebaut habe das
kann das könnte ich schon mal in meine consulting skill ist es schreibe ja consulting skill skill
ist auf auf mein link in profil das muss ich sofort bei mir auch eintragen auf link in sekunde
ich habe das login jetzt ja nicht hier dass sonst hätte ich das sofort ja ich mein ich
bin jetzt nicht nur cloud native agile github solution chief engineer officer ich bin jetzt
auch noch netzwerkexperte in die liste für quatsch quatsch ich schreibe ich schreibe
doch nicht allen ernstes in die skillliste rein cisco cisco erfahrung bgp nur weil ich
im package racer drei kommandos ausgeführt habe da will da will doch irgendjemand dass
ich das vielleicht mal mache stellt euch das mal vor stellt euch mal vor ich schreibe das
in meine skillliste rein und irgendwann zwei jahre später kommt dann einer zu mir und
sagt dann max ich guck mal kennst du dich damit nicht aus kannst du das nicht mal machen
ok aber im vergleich zu anderen bin ich wirklich profi weil wir hatten mal einen bei uns der
hatten die bewerbung reingeschrieben fortschrittliche oder fortgeschrittene oder advanced ich glaube
fast überhaupt echt advanced wemwär wie schreibt man das in seine bewerbung rein
keine ahnung der hat fortgeschrittene verkenntnisse oder haben wir ihn gefragt ja was hast du schon
mit vmwär gemacht und da hat er jetzt ohne scheiß es ist es ist es ist wahr ja ich schwöre
auf mein package racer er hat gesagt ich habe schon mal eine ubuntu vm installiert in vmwär
also das waren fortgeschrittene vmwär kenntnisse und der wusste aber jetzt jetzt kommt jetzt
kommt da eigentliche da eigentliche pains champ dabei der wusste gar nicht dass das drinnen steht in
seiner in seiner bewerbung und seiner skillliste das wusste der gar nicht das hat sein headhunter
dude einfach frisiert da hat er irgendwas reingeschrieben was es überhaupt nicht war
wahrscheinlich haben sie den jetzt beim bulgarischen provider an den router gelassen
vor allem wsx workstation da hat nichts davon stand da drin das war wahrscheinlich aber das kann
euch echt passieren wenn euch irgendwelche headhunter typen vermitteln wollen was macht
ich muss mal ganz wir machen gleich weiter ich muss mal kurz youtube ich muss mal kurz gucken
wie sich mein aktuelles video so schlägt warum kriege ich warum kriege ich mein video hier nicht
empfohlen was ist hier los warum warum nicht gut ging ja routine ging jetzt jetzt simulieren
wir gleich wenn man missed advertise das müssen wir auch noch machen und das video läuft doch
ganz gut ich meine diese asubi asubi tips videos sind natürlich nicht so der renner wie andere
videos das letzte asubi tips video hat 12 hatte 12k aber das ist so ein video ich glaube das geht
über die zeit immer weiter und immer weiter und kriegt immer ein bisschen weiter views das ist so
und das ist so ein video für für long term so was ja wohingegen so was hier new world beta oder
oder irgendwie oder meine meinungen zum neuen windows oder so dass das das ist eher so so
kurzzeit zeug das interessiert dann schnell kein mehr so aber scheint er den leuten zu gefallen
poggers dann machen wir mal weiter aber ich bin echt schon mal begeistert dass das geht
mal gucken dass der kram gespeichert ist ok so und jetzt kommt der bulgarische provider ins spiel
wie wechselst du so schnell zwischen anwendung das ist eine vm das ist eine das ist eine vm
ich tipp gehe rein und raus in die vm mit also windows desktops wechselt du mit control
windows tasten feiltasten wechselst du die desktops durch und wenn du aus der vm raus
willst drückst du control alt und wenn du das ein bisschen geübt hast drückst du control alt
und danach direkt control windows tasten also so das geht dann geht dann in einer in einer
einer bewegung im endeffekt also drückst control alt um aus vm rauszukommen control windows zum
rüber switchen oder nach rechts in dem fall sieht natürlich ein bisschen merkwürdig aus wenn ich
von windows 11 auf windows 10 switchen umgedreht so jetzt kommt der bulgarische provider ins spiel
so wie machen wir das jetzt wir brauchen eine verbindung vom telekom natürlich glas glas
fiber fiber verbindung von fe5 auf den bulgarischen gut aber auch fe5 da kann ich
mir einfacher merken so das ist jetzt jeder jebait der bulgarische jebait router den nennen wir auch
jebaited der heißt nicht pains champ der heißt jebaited so ist viel besser alles klar
gut das heißt wir müssen jetzt erstmal das was microsoft ja wohl gemacht hat übrigens
es war glaube ich nicht microsoft selbst das ging das ging ja irgendwie über noch über
einen zwischen zwischen hopp und microsoft hat an diesem dem router von diesem zwischenhop vertraut
beim annunzen von von routen aber trotzdem haben sie nicht überprüft so
ich könnte auch hier drüber einschalten aber nein wir machen es über die kohano zeilen wir wollen
ja was lernen also interface fast internet 5 ich bin jetzt wo drauf auf dem bulgarischen router
dem geben wir jetzt erstmal eine ip wir brauchen ein neues interconnect netz was nehmen wir da
machen wir was ganz anderes 172 keine ahnung das da 172 172 wobei wenn wir wenn wir lokal
brauchen lokal wollen wir eher das oder 20 20 das ist eine gute idee 20 20 wir können auch ich
meine wir können auch einfach 20 20 20 nehmen wir müssen doch gar nicht privat bleiben das juckt
uns im packet tracer noch gar nicht wir nehmen einfach 20 20 20 als netz so wunderbar dann ist
das kein problem da kann ich das alles einstellen also interface die haben wir schon also ip
address wollen wir dem ding jetzt also wir sind jetzt hier auf diesem interface auf dem ersten
oder auf dem auf dem klasse faser interface vom bulgarischen router ok ip address 20 20 20 punkt
keine ahnung 1 255 255 255 242 no shutdown port hochfahren so das changed state to down ach so
ja klar weil der microsoft router noch nicht hochgefahren ist slash 31 ok die idee wäre ich
jetzt gar nicht gekommen aber ich glaube wir können es uns erlauben uns steht der gesamte
ipv4 adress raum zur verfügung so dann gehen wir zum microsoft router gehen wir zum microsoft ich
mache es mal kurz ein bisschen kleiner im vergleich zum aktuell zum internet steht uns tatsächlich
der komplette ipv6 der komplette ipv4 raum zur verfügung so interface fa 5 slash 0 so
ip address habe ich schon wieder vergessen was ich bei dem eingestellt habe ich glaube bei dem
habe ich eingestellt die eins hinten das heißt der microsoft router kriegt jetzt die zwei hinten
also 20 20 20 punkt 2 255 255 255 255 252 no shutdown gut link zwischen dem g baited router
und microsoft steht ping ane das muss ich erstmal hier raus ping 20 20 20 punkt 1
funktioniert und zwar sich selbst kann auch ping ok die verbindung steht noch ist überhaupt kein
problem bis jetzt juckt diese route zwischen telekom und microsoft noch überhaupt gar nichts ok
jetzt müssen wir bgp konfigurieren zwischen denen hier also da muss ich jetzt mal überlegen wie ich
das machen mal gucken ob ich jetzt aus dem kopf hinkriege pass mal auf big brain time router bgp
ich bin jetzt auf dem bulgarischen router drauf was was kriegt der für eine für eine nummer hat
ihr mal also as 69 ist die telekom s4 20 ist die microsoft was kriegt der bulgarische provider
für eins 1337 na sonderlich heckermann mäßig ist er ja nicht 666 das finde ich gut
666 das ist schon gut ok bgp 666 und jetzt musste ich sagen network ok wie etwa heißt einfach mal
nur jetzt gerade mal nur zum testen sein eigenes ne moment chat wie war das re jetzt testen wir
mal ob die jetzt big brain time ob das jetzt funktioniert redistribute connected boah big
brain time jetzt müssen wir nicht von hand reinschreiben jawoll so und jetzt müssen wir
beim t jetzt müssen wir bei microsoft router jetzt müssen wir microsoft router noch die bgp
verbindung mit dem da herstellen an der erst mal die erst mal den nachbar noch mal den nachbar
konfigurieren also neighbor kurz checken hier natürlich doof dass man das jetzt nicht so
anklicken kann das ist die zwei es ist gut ich habe sogar einheitlich gemacht also neighbor
ist 2020 20.2 also die ip von microsoft router wie ging es jetzt remote s remote s ist am start
remote s das microsoft microsoft as name genau muss man sonst noch was machen ne enter und
ich glaube das war es das muss ich bei microsoft umgedreht auch noch einrichten also router
bgp 20 so neighbor 20 20 20.1 die ip vom bulgarischen router remote s 666 neighbor ab so und jetzt
gucken wir mal und jetzt sollte ich hier nämlich show ip root jetzt sollte ich hier alles drin
stehen haben guckt jetzt habe ich auch das netz drinnen also na gut das bulgarische netz kenne
ich eh schon jetzt gucken wir mal auf dem telekom router ob der dem das jetzt mitteilt da bin ich
jetzt mal gespannt show ip ip root funktioniert guck mal der telekom router kennt jetzt das netz
vom bulgarischen router telekom kennt jetzt das netz vom bulgarischen router das ist schon mal
gut er hat sein eigenes transfernetz zu zu advertise das reicht ja erst mal und es reicht ja auch um
es kaputt zu machen dem ich gleich telekom telekom sachen rausschicken so das bedeutet ich kann
jetzt durch den eintrag von meinem kunden pc ein ping machen an den bulgarischen router also an
20 20 20.2 und es funktioniert bän nicht dass man das machen will aber wir wissen dass es
deswegen funktioniert guck mal simulation guck es euch mal an wie leist es jetzt funktioniert
flupp geht zum telekom router telekom router schickt zum microsoft router microsoft das war
das intervall das war das interface von microsoft router abbruch 1 geht aber trotzdem simulation
ping ping ping ping geht hier hoch und ping geht zurück nice funktioniert ok so und jetzt
und jetzt kommt jetzt kommt der big brain jetzt jetzt kommt die oder was ist big brain jetzt kommt jetzt
müssen wir das machen was die beim bulgarischen router verkackt haben jetzt muss ich nur noch
irgendwie hinkriegen dass die route beliebter ist vom bulgarischen anbieter als die telekom
route wie auch immer das funktioniert jetzt bau mal auf dem bulgaren interface loup 1 warum
rare parrotmusik
die kann es dann auch von überall erreichen ach so ja ist doch ist doch ist doch in ordnung
so das heißt ich connecte hier jetzt mal ein netz dran wie von der telekom dann sollte er
automatisch das etwa teisen oder ich ich ich versuche es mal ich versuche es mal so also wir
sind jetzt wir gehen auf den bulgarischen router mal gucken was jetzt passiert da bin ich jetzt
echt mal gespannt was jetzt was jetzt passiert also bulgarischer router ich advertise da jetzt
das netz von der telekom drüber 1 2 2 1 6 8 ne das geht gar nicht das muss in der routing tabelle
drin stehen sonst kann ich das nicht advertisen das heißt ich muss jetzt an den bulgarischen
router auf jeden fall noch mal zumindest dass es dass ich jetzt testen kann das netz von der
telekom dran hängen weil solange sich eine routing tabelle ist kann ich ja nicht advertisen ok jetzt
jetzt war es kaputt jetzt war was jetzt war was kaputt der kriegt jetzt hier in den interface
was nehmen wir da für ein interface was ist hier noch frei fast es hat nicht 00 wir müssten
wahrscheinlich prioritäten dann hochsetzen also jebaited da sind wir hier interface ne
und t interface fa 0 0 ip address so und jetzt geben wir dem irgendwas aus diesem netz hier
also 192 168 1 punkt was auch immer ist egal 200 255 255 255 0 so und jetzt sollten wir
damit eigentlich das netz kaputt machen wenn ich das richtig sehe so hier kommt schon bgp
advertisement raus was dafür muss man rootmaps bauen was muss man so jetzt geht ja schon das
bgp advertisement raus weißt du ob das mit dem mit was ob das damit dann funktioniert
beziehungsweise das bulgarische netz so gemacht oder anders bei was es kann ich kann es geht
unmittelbar ich kann dir nicht folgen aber so ungefähr muss das gelaufen sein bei dem
ausfall so jetzt gucken wir mal in das bgp ach du scheiße ich spreche ich spreche ich
spreche kein bgp ich spreche kein bgp ich weiß nicht was das bgp ist alter der packet
tracer kann es auch nicht variable data sagt er nur der announced zumindest dass er der
announced jetzt wahrscheinlich dass er ein neues netz hat das ist das netz von der telekom
es kann sein dass ich noch irgendwelche prioritäten ändern muss dass es dann wirklich kaputt geht
bgp ist empfängt er der schickt es weiter und der telekom router wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
stecken was der fack guck mal auf dem ms router die routing tabelle ja warum ist das daun
unsupported ok hat er das mitbekommen dass es nicht funktioniert show root nee was
show ip nee nee das das hat er hat er nicht hat er nicht gemacht das hat er nicht hat er
nicht gemacht der schickt ihm jetzt zurück alter du kack spaß was schickst mir hier für kack
pakete nee das das juckt er nicht das juckt er nicht also ich muss den ich muss da irgendwie
noch wahrscheinlich muss ich meine ja wie wie sage ich dem jetzt dass meine route besser ist
aber der versucht ja noch zu bild zu advertising alter ist ein fa 0 an bulgarischen router überhaupt
ab ja klar dass sie eben gesehen die haben sachen ausgetauscht also das allein hat noch
das allein hat noch nicht gereicht um es kaputt zu machen das allein hat noch nicht gereicht
so das heißt ich muss jetzt ich müsste doch jetzt dem irgendwie dem bulgarischen router
sagen also wie kann ich denn sagen dass das meint dass die dass die route hier besser
ist kann ich so eine kann ich noch eine priorität angeben show bgp sum oh jetzt wird es entwarnst
hier was show bgp in welchem in welchem modus muss ich das machen
muss ich das im router bgp wo bin ich jetzt drauf microsoft 420 ich weiß nicht wo ich
es anzeigen muss also show ip bgp sum summary ja der sagt mir er kennt was er was er was
sagt das er kennt die zwei die zwei neighbors und jetzt ja da habe ich jetzt keinen plan
kann man nicht irgendwie bei wenn ich das wenn ich das ankündige kann ich nicht sagen
meine meine bei mir ist die route viel billiger du musst doch angeben dass du die netze propagierst
mache ich doch mache ich doch für prioritäten musst du gut merken nein nein nein das mache
ich jetzt nicht das klingt kompliziert das klingt das klingt kompliziert ok also anscheinend
reicht das nicht wenn man einfach nur das gleiche netz doppelt advertised anhand von
was entscheidet er denn wenn er doppelt advertised bekommt was die was er nimmt über das ganze
noch mal show running konfig und dann section show ip was war das summary kann man jetzt
immer nicht merken address ne interfaces interface interface interface ich muss mal
ein bisschen größer machen ok package asfeifert das kann man damit nicht machen also wo ist
denn überhaupt ist jetzt also der sollte das eigentlich advertise es berechnet berechnet
den günstigsten weg ja das dumme ist nur der weg ist ja gleich lang jeweils ein router
dazwischen weil wisst ihr was wir machen einfach nicht machen ich noch ein router zwischen
zwischen das könnte man jetzt ausprobieren ich könnte noch ein router dazwischen machen
und dann und dann gucken ob er das ob er das checkt die sollte nicht propagiert wenn doch
doch ich habe da ich habe da nichts geblockt die propagiert wie er witzig wie er lustig
ist es funktioniert ja alles es funktioniert ja alles es geht nur nicht also was nicht
funktioniert ist er macht es nicht kaputt was ja gar nicht so schlecht ist also das das
ok das können wir noch mal ausprobieren also aktuell ist der weg hier überall gleich lang
das heißt wir machen da jetzt noch mal ein noch mal ein router hier dazwischen das muss
ich jetzt das probiere ich da hoffe ich da hoffe ich mal ob da jetzt mein gehirn noch
mitmacht da muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken ok wir haben jetzt noch ein router das ist
ja das ist eindeutig ach der etwa heißt das nicht weil das interface down ist es reicht
nicht wenn man dem das einfach anlegt also ich habe das interface ja selbst auf abgesetzt
ich meine das können wir können wir ja machen pc dran verbinden jetzt pc mit f a 0 f a 0
pc pc ach quatsch moment moment das ist ja das ist ja ganz pingelig wir müssen wir müssen
ja nen wir müssen ja nen crossover kabel nehmen ok was habe ich jetzt gemacht das ist
ja sonst zu pingelig null null pass ok dann da gebe ich dem jetzt auch mal eine lp aus
dem bereich warum nicht und ich stelle mal ein gateway ein das bringt das bringt jetzt
zwar nicht aber 1 2 2 1 6 8 1 punkt das habe ich ihm jetzt gegeben 100 schon wieder vergessen
200 200 ist der gateway so interface 1 punkt 50 ok wir gucken mal ob ich meinen router
abhängen kann jop funst ok etwa hat das jetzt advertised schauen wir mal wir gehen auf den
microsoft router ne show ip root ne also es juckt den auch nicht das das juckt den nicht
das hat das hat crossover kabel ja ja gut das will ja dass man die die noob sachen ausprobieren
kann also wann nimmt man crossover kabel wann nimmt man straight straight wie heißen die
dinger noch mal was ist das gegenteil von crossover kabel man braucht das so selten
kannst du bitte labels mit den ip's machen ja ja wir machen labels das ist sonst sonst
bin ich zu sonst bin ich pick da auch nicht mehr durch also labels place note so das hier
ist 1.100 das ist wait wait wait label 1 2 2 1 6 8 1 punkt 100 das hier ist 1 2 2 1
6 8 1 punkt 1 das ist 1 2 2 1 6 8 1 punkt 2 5 4 das ist 1 2 2 2 2 punkt 2 5 4 ja und
das hier ist da muss ich nachgucken 10 das ist 10 1 das ist 10 2 1 30 dahinter und das
da ist 10 punkt 10 punkt 10 punkt 2 der router ist echt ja macht macht aber kein unterschied
kann man das editieren so ok also das zwischennetz hier können wir noch machen 2 2 2 20 2 2
20 20 20 2 meine güde 2 und das da ist 20 20 20 1 so huge labeling es könnte ja sein
dass das ding jetzt der meinung ist ok ich habe beide netze advertised aber ich macht
ich mache das interface mal dauernd leute ich mache dieses interface ich fahre dieses interface
mal runter mal gucken was dann passiert wir machen jetzt f a 4 0 machen wir machen wir
zu inter interface f a 4 0 shutdown achtung bäm so down interface und jetzt mal gucken
was er was was er was er jetzt sagt show ip root warum kennt er warum kennt er das
jetzt nicht habe ich irgendwas habe ich irgendwas verkehrt konfiguriert was bis zu bis zu 90
sekunden warten ok was war das andere show show bgp ne schau ja state ach guck mal da
denkt immer noch das ist oben dabei ist es schon längst dauen ah jetzt sagt er jetzt
sagt er dauen state 4 ne state 4 der hat das noch nicht gecheckt dass das weg ist kann
das sein
man checkt ja das denn kannst du im package was was unten links kannst du im package tracer
die zeit oh habe ich gerade 10 minuten vorgespult ok bäm was das hier power cycle ne ne ne
moment mein power cycle kann ich die geräte nicht muss ich die konfig nicht erst noch
speichern hat er die konfig überhaupt gespeichert von meinen von meinen routern jetzt nicht
dass die moment moment moment erstmal erstmal alle konfig speichern konf safe ne so ne wie
geht das jetzt ach wie er ach du scheiße das das weiß ich nicht mehr wie er mem right
to nv ok passt alles klar ja ja ja ist gesavt wie er memory 5 hat es gesavt und jebaited
jebaited ist auch gesavt ok mal gucken was der jetzt der meint der hat es nicht gecheckt
dass es dass es dauen ist gab es nicht clear bgp wahrscheinlich ok das hatte das hatte
ich fahre jetzt einfach mal und wenn ich habe das interface doch runtergefahren was clear
ip bgp ach so ähm nicht ernst wie das ist ab will er mich verarschen hä es ergibt
doch überhaupt keinen sinn ich meine irgendwas irgendwas verkehrt ok das netz ist rausgeflogen
alles klar wunderbar aber warum warum ist das netz rausgeflogen der sollte doch dieses
netz jetzt advertised bekommen von vom bulgarischen router ok ich skippe ich skippe die zeit
nochmal vor vielleicht braucht er da einfach ein bisschen für ok jetzt jetzt funktioniert
gut also anscheinend ich vermute mal dass es einfach so ist dadurch dass der telekom
router und der bulgarische router jeweils direkt connected sind sieht er sich nicht
dazu gezwungen irgendwie da was zu überschreiben weil er die länge überall gleich ist es
reicht mir mal ob das sinnvoll ob das sein kann wenn ich jetzt hier dazwischen noch mal
ein extra hopp mache dann könnte es sein dass das funktioniert was ich vor habe aber
das ist mir eigentlich zu zu low low low da ist mein gehirn eigentlich gerade nicht mehr
wirklich in der lage dazu kannst du nicht einfach einen teil von dem telekom netz adverten
kleinere maske sollte auch höhere prio haben doch kann ich ich kann ich machen ich wusste
nicht dass das einen unterschied macht kann ich machen gut das heißt jetzt jetzt mache
ich den link erst mal wieder an und dann sollte im prinzip die telekom zwar wieder advertisen
aber es sollte sich nichts es sollte sich nichts ändern das das können wir jetzt ausprobieren
also ich mache jetzt erst mal das interface wieder an interface wir können auch hier
das interface hier interface no shutdown bäm ich mag das ich mag das cisco interface eigentlich
gucke hat's gecheckt aber er denkt immer noch ach guckte mal an ach guckte mal einer an
aus irgendwelchen gründen hat das hier priorität vielleicht weil die ip kleiner ist kann das
sein jetzt aber ohne scheiß der muss ja an irgendwas festmachen wenn der zwei sachen
advertised bekommt welches priorität hat also irgendeine logik egal wie abgedreht muss
es da geben also sprich der guckt der guckt genau as nummer ip nummer was kleiner ist
irgendwie sowas die genau die as nummer ist kleiner das ist nämlich as 69 und das hier
ist as 666 das kann man das können wir noch drüber schreiben wir machen das jetzt mal
was richtig professionell was was ich war was was zum was macht er hier ich will ich will
ich will aber keine keine color film outline outline outline black mega hässlich aber
funktional das halbes halbes visio alter halbes halbes visio das ding das hat er mich
gebetet mein gott ist es schlecht meine güte also wie big brain visio ist es nicht so so
ich lasse jetzt einfach so so weil das da ich muss es jetzt mal zur besseren und besseren
verständnis das da ist as 69 das da ist as 420 und das da ist as 666 jetzt erkennt man
das besser so dass das ergibt sinn die die as nummer ist niedriger pack a trace aus
ne cute anwählen das ist doch 100 pro java das doch kein cute so hässlich wie das ist
ich kann gleich mal nachgucken was es ist so das heißt ok irgendjemand hat gesagt ich
soll mal versuchen ein kleineres netz zu zu advertisen kann ich ausprobieren machen wir
jetzt mal gucken wir mal gucken wir mal also dann gehen wir mal hier auf den bulgarischen
router sagen interface interface was war das ffa 00 oder so null slash null wie weiß jemand
wie man sich die ip anzeigen lassen kann wenn man hier in diesem konfig interface drin
ist wenn ich den konfig interface drin kann ich mir anzeigen lassen welche ip das interface
gerade hat doch zumindest wir ändern jetzt einfach mal die ip wir machen das wir machen
das jetzt kleiner also das ist 200 und das ist 50 na gut da müssen wir noch später
ändern also jetzt ip also ip address hier aktuell hat das 200 dann machen wir das jetzt
einfach so dass das kriegt auch wirklich 200 aber slash 30 1.200 slash 30 da geht ja nicht
maske 255 255 255 255 255 255 252 p.m.
Warum ist das eine Bad Mask?
Muss doch funktionieren.
Moment, Moment, das müssen wir jetzt checken.
Wir sind ja, wir haben hier die Tools, 1.200 slash 30, natürlich funktioniert das Hausman.
Warum ist das, warum ist das eine ungültige Mask?
Muss ich das, muss ich das Interface vorher down machen oder sowas?
Bad Mask for Address, aber warum?
Aber 2.550 geht oder was?
Was?
Ach so Moment, ah Lul, um, ach so, ach jetzt weiß ich was ihr meint, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, genau, das ergibt Sinn, 2.520, ja, send to neighbor, unsupported null bytes, ok, alles
klar, was auch immer, oh, oh, guck mal, die schicken sich Dinger, die schicken sich Dinger,
ok, was sagt der Microsoft Router jetzt, der Microsoft Router, es juckt ihn nicht, es juckt
ihn nicht, es ist ihm egal, er kehrt nicht, er kehrt nicht, ok, wir spulen die Zeit mal
vor, bam, ich müsste da 100% irgendeinen Zwischenhopp oder so machen, dann wird es
wahrscheinlich funktionieren, ah, haha, guck mal, ok, das hat jetzt funktioniert, jetzt
hätten wir alle IPs kaputt gemacht, also genau, doch, doch jetzt funktioniert es, jetzt funktioniert
es, jetzt haben wir alle DSL Kunden kaputt gemacht, die IPs aus dieser Range verwenden,
ok, das stellen wir jetzt nach, das stellen wir jetzt nach, ich glaube, ich glaube jetzt
funktioniert es, also das war Big Brain Tipp einfach was kleineres zu nehmen, also das hier
müsste jetzt, das hier müsste noch, nein ich will das nicht löschen, sondern das hier
müsste jetzt noch funktionieren, wenn ich den Server pinge, 22, oh, moment, haben die
mit dem Telekom Router jetzt das eigene Netz announced oder was, aber der Telekom Router
hat die, ich glaube jetzt ist es, jetzt ist es vorbei, ich glaube jetzt hat es sich irgendwie,
warum hat denn der Telekom Router jetzt das Netz von Microsoft nicht mehr, muss man das
jetzt verstehen, warum hat der Telekom Router das Netz von Microsoft nicht mehr, aha, jetzt
hat es, jetzt hat es es wieder, ok, ich war zu, ich war zu schnell, ich war, ich war zu
schnell, ok, jetzt geht es, also wir können pingen, ok, noch geht das, wir können pingen,
also und unser DSL Kunde hat jetzt allerdings eine andere IP, unser DSL Kunde bekommt jetzt,
also der Typ stöpselt sein Modem aus und reconnectet sich und bekommt eine andere IP
und zwar er bekommt jetzt die IP, er bekommt jetzt die IP anstatt 192.168.1.1 bekommt
er die IP 192.168.1.201, das kann ja immer bei der Einwahl passieren und jetzt, also
wenn jetzt alles funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle, dann landen die Antwortspakete
nicht mehr beim DSL Kunde, sondern beim bulgarischen Provider, der damit nichts anfangen kann.
So, also der hat sich jetzt neu eingewählt, hat eine neue IP bekommen und wir pingen jetzt
mal Simulation an, wir pingen jetzt den Server, ne Moment, wir pingen jetzt den Server, so
ICMP, am Moment, falsch, falscher PC, Kegwaid, Command Prompt, ok, wir pingen jetzt den Server,
ich lasse den anderen Mist hier erstmal durchlaufen, ok, also DSL Kunde pingt den Server, also
neue AB Request, weil neue IP nach der Einwahl bekommen, AB Request aufgelöst, alles gut,
so ICMP Package geht auf die Reise. Telekom Router kennt die Route zum Server, gar kein
Problem, Microsoft Router kennt auch die Route zum Server, so, aber der Rückweg funktioniert
nicht mehr, wenn es jetzt so funktioniert, wie ich mir das gedacht habe, weil der Rückweg
ist ja überschrieben quasi vom bulgarischen Router, der Router hier denkt jetzt, der Weg
zu 201 geht da drüber, so, bis dahin gehts und jetzt sollte das falsch abbiegen, haha
und schon gehen alle DSL Kunden nicht mehr, die eine IP aus diesem Netz bekommen und der
bulgarische Provider kann damit nichts mehr anfangen, genau das, so war der Ausfall von
der Telekom vor ein paar Jahren, äh, was laufe ich denn für ein Scheiß vor zwei Tagen,
nicht vor ein paar Jahren, vor zwei Tagen, genau so muss das gewesen sein. Kann man das
irgendwie halbwegs nachvollziehen jetzt Leute, mal Frage, jetzt mal ehrlich, legit Frage,
kann man das irgendwie nachvollziehen? Mach dieses Label da, mach dieses Label da weg,
das verwirrt nur, ich mach hier Label dran, unwichtig, alte IP, neue IP,
alt, gut, ein,
hoffentlich selektiert er jetzt das richtige Delete, ja, ja genau so ist das, hast du Packet
Ressort aufgemacht, ja, also wenn der Kunde diese IP vom Provider bekommt, dann geht alles,
wenn der Kunde diese IP vom Provider bekommt, dann geht es nicht und zwar weil, ich versuche
es jetzt nochmal zu zeigen, also was jetzt passiert ist folgendes, ja ja die Liste mal,
also was jetzt passiert ist folgendes, der bulgarische Provider hat einen Teil vom Telekom
Netz quasi, man kann nicht sagen, für sich beansprucht, irgendjemand hat sich vertippt
beim bulgarischen Provider und hat sich verschrieben und hat ausversehen Teile des Telekom Netzes
jetzt angekündigt, dass es bei ihm liegt, weil es ein kleinerer Teil vom Telekom Netz
ist, als die Telekom selbst advertised, hat das Vorrang, das bedeutet, das Paket vom Kunde
läuft so zum Server und auf dem Rückweg biegt es falsch ab, weil der Router bei Microsoft
denkt, aha diese IP, die ist ja gar nicht da im Telekom Netz, diese viel spezifischere
IP wurde mir angekündigt in diesem Netz vom bulgarischen Provider, also der Hinweg geht,
der Rückweg geht nicht, das sieht man ja auch in der Simulation, also sprich, wenn ich jetzt
hier DSL kunde, mach einen Ping, Hinweg funktioniert, weil PC zu seinem eigenen Router kein Problem
findet er, findet er ja, kein Ding, der eigene Router kennt auch den Weg zur Microsoft Router,
der Microsoft Router kennt natürlich den angeschlossenen Server, der angeschlossene Server schickt
jetzt eine Antwort zurück, mit der Ziel IP, das kann ich euch jetzt mal zeigen, mit der
Ziel IP, Alter, what the fuck, geh mal auf, mit der Ziel IP 1201, das ist die neue IP
vom DSL Kunde, so und hier an der Stelle passiert jetzt der Fehler, diese Route, die genau darauf
matcht auf diesen Bereich, wo er jetzt eine IP draus hat, die hat der bulgarische Provider
angekündigt, dass die jetzt bei ihm ist, so und der Rückweg funktioniert jetzt nicht
so wie gedacht, sondern der Rückweg ist, ja er biegt jetzt zum bulgarischen Provider ab
und der hat keine Ahnung was er damit machen soll, das ergibt, ja ja doch jetzt ergibt
das jetzt ergibt das Echt Sinn, so und wirklich kann ich euch auch zeigen, dass es, sobald
ich jetzt, ich stöpsel jetzt mal ein DSL Modem ein paar mal rein und raus, ihr seht
auch es funktioniert nicht, ich stöpsel jetzt mal ein DSL Modem ein paar mal rein und raus
und bekomme jetzt keine Ahnung, eine neue IP, 192.168.1.5 zum Beispiel, ja, so jetzt
gehe ich wieder hier rein, Simulation an, pinge, also die Handhabung ist teilweise
ein bisschen, Pange wieder den Server, so das erste überspringen wir jetzt mal, zack zack
zack, so jetzt geht, jetzt geht der Ping, jetzt geht der Ping los, ups, Moment hab ich
mich vertippt, was hab ich gemacht, ach ich hab den Gateway geändert, ok ich hab, ich
hab die Route IP geändert, ok ich stöpsel jetzt mal ein DSL Modem ein paar mal rein
und raus und bekomme jetzt als IP 192.168.1.72, so genau, also ich hab mich jetzt noch eingewählt
und bekomme, hab eine neue IP bekommen und jetzt machen wir den Kunde, den Kunde PC
wieder auf, zack, Desktop, so diese IP liegt jetzt nicht in dem Bereich, die der bulgarische
Provider angekündigt hat, jetzt pingen wir wieder den Microsoft Server und jetzt werdet
ihr sehen, jetzt geht der Ping auch, Achtung, das hat ja vorher auch schon geklappt, aber
jetzt klappt auch gleich der Rückweg, bam, jetzt geht der Rückweg auch und jetzt kommt
der Ping auch wieder an, weil jetzt ist die IP nämlich nicht mehr in dem Netz, was der
bulgarische Provider angekündigt hat, der bulgarische Provider hat quasi eine Untermenge
in dem Fall von dem Telekom Netz angekündigt, dass das jetzt zu ihm gehört und jetzt funktioniert
das, nice, das ist cool, das ist echt nice, das wir jetzt mal nachgestellt haben, also
ich gehe davon aus, dass ziemlich ähnlich zu dem was wir jetzt gebaut haben, das passiert
nicht, also ich hab's gesaved, wir können's doch mal save, Telekom, Big Brain, ich gehe
davon aus, dass sehr sehr ähnlich zu dem was wir hier nachgebaut haben, der Fehler vor
ein paar Tagen zustande gekommen ist, also vom Ablauf her würde ich sagen mehr oder
weniger genauso, aber natürlich deutlich komplexer mit was Routern die beteiligt sind,
und was hätte der Microsoft Router noch machen müssen um das Advertisement zu verifizieren,
also da kenn ich mich nicht so richtig mit aus, es gibt wohl zwei Varianten die man machen
kann, einmal kann man das irgendwie signieren lassen, dass nicht irgendjemand random was
advertisen kann und es gibt wohl irgendwie auch die Möglichkeit custommäßig was zu
skripten, dass man dann nachguckt okay, gehört überhaupt dieses Netz was da angekündigt
wird, eben diesem Provider der das ankündigt, aber sag mal so mit diesen Settings wie wir
jetzt hier haben kann man nichts dagegen machen, also es könnte jetzt auch hier irgendjemand
dran gehen, man muss ja auch mal dazu sagen, vielleicht nochmal zu erklären warum das eigentlich
nicht so schlimm ist, diese Verbindung hier die muss ja von Hand angelegt werden, es kann
sich jetzt ja nicht irgendwie einer an den Telekom Router stöpseln und irgendwas advertisen,
also du musst ja quasi schon dem anderen Provider, die müssen sich ja gegenseitig
vertrauen indem sie sich in die Config eintragen untereinander, also das Transfernetz muss
manuell konfiguriert werden auf den Routern, dass überhaupt die Verbindung geht, und dann
müssen sie noch eine BGP Config machen und sich gegenseitig, also die müssen sich erstmal
gegenseitig trauen, deswegen passiert da auch so wenig, die trauen sich halt gegenseitig
und normalerweise tippt halt auch keiner Scheiße ein in die Config, Router sind so 20.Jahrhundert
ja total, ich finde wir sollten Routerless etablieren oder, Serverless haben wir schon,
ich würde sagen als nächstes wird es Zeit für Routerless, ist der logische nächste
Schritt, aber ich meine Wireless haben wir ja schon, ok ich gebe zu das war ein sehr
pains-champinger-Witz, Computerless, aber ich bin begeistert Leute, guck dir mal jetzt
habe ich es wenigstens verstanden, jetzt habe ich es wenigstens verstanden, Brainless haben
wir schon, aber jetzt habe ich es wenigstens verstanden was das Problem ist, so ich wollte
ja ein Video dazu machen, allerdings deutlich weniger komplex, stell euch mal vor ich erzähle
den Leuten auf YouTube sowas, die sitzen auf YouTube da und denken sich dann im Prinzip
nur noch, ich glaube auf YouTube kommt da echt keiner mehr mit, das vorbei, machst du das
morgen mit einem Switch und drei Raspberry Pi's, ne ganz bestimmt nicht, also auf YouTube
kann ich das nicht, auf YouTube mache ich die stark vereinfachte 6-7 Minuten Variante
davon, vielleicht zeige ich das nochmal, jetzt mal eine Frage an euch, an sich ist das hier
doch ziemlich anschaulich oder, vielleicht jetzt ohne genauere Erklärung aber nur mal
zum zeigen mit den Paketen, also das hier ist eigentlich ziemlich cool zum nachverfolgen
oder, da kann man dann sagen ok so läuft das Paket normalerweise, dann funktioniert das
auch auf dem Rückweg alles, aber wenn man jetzt eben IP aus dem falschen Netz bekommt,
dann gehe ich dann dahin und sage so ich habe jetzt Pech und bekomme falsche IP bei
der Einwahl und mache das ganze nochmal, dann sieht man das Package kommt zwar beim Server
an, aber biegt auf dem Rückweg falsch ab, das ist glaube ich recht anschaulich das ganze,
das finde ich gut, das sollte ich machen, ich meine die Grafiken, also diese Bearbeitungsfunktion
hier von Packet Tracer sind ja schon ein bisschen fail, gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass, Moment
mal nochmal, ist das hier die Form oder was soll das sein, ok, wir machen jetzt einfach
mal gucken, ob das schön ist, gelb, Monk, Monks, was ist das, gehst du mal weg, hier
nochmal, hier, so, guck mal, ihr Leute jetzt sieht das aus wie in irgendwelchen Cisco Dokumenten
wir haben auch immer so eine komische gelbe gelbe geschichte wobei das stimmt ja gar nicht
so genau dass das as 69 ist der dsl kunde pc na doch doch ja doch stimmt das netz gehört
ja dazu aber das ist nicht as 69 dass die ip gehört da gar nicht dabei aber das kann
man schon so dabei machen das ist wenn aus elf jahr als 69 kommen mal das noch mal
schnell hübsch da kann ich das auch für das video verwenden so als 69 dann brauchen wir
jetzt hier viel color irgendwas ein bisschen ein bisschen blau blau wie hässlich meine güte was
ist das denn ok schön ist schön ist was anderes aber es funktioniert
und was kriegen die da oben was was kriegt was kriegen die bulgaren für eine farbe
na geil jetzt kann ich was ist im hintergrund heute was ist da im hintergrund das sind die
weißen kästen die ich vorher gemalt habe die ich aber nicht gesehen habe okay okay ich glaube
das versteht man so das lasse ich jetzt alles klar okay ich gehe jetzt mal kurz in chat
bei ein paar sachen beantworten als dann noch irgendwas übrig geblieben ist meine güte da
kannst du nichts ersetzen naja ich sag mal so bei youtube sind halt mehr leute auch grad bei
mir alles mögliche machen jetzt nicht unbedingt IT technik haben und dann was in der tiefe wo man
hier mit so was was anfangen kann hier will ich nicht gar so sehr quälen mit so was ja ohne
kupane das geht ja nix warum von frankfurt abkoppeln wo bei dir im keller oder oder wo
stellst du stellst du es zur verfügung kommen wir stellen ein paar racks bei ihm in keller
auf geht's war davon abgesehen jetzt mal realistisch betracht du kannst dich ja nicht
von frankfurt irgendwie abkoppeln also deine daten werden ziemlich sicher durch den d6 gehen ob du
es willst oder nicht mr. futz 2k dankeschön für den sub
das codes habe ich nicht übersehen dankeschön für den sub singlor poggers matrix hd auch am start
so habe ich irgendwas übersehen wenn der microsoft router noch mal zwischen routet das nicht
straight zum ziel router könnte das sekundäre das wieder fixen das falsche adverteisen alle
also wenn du hier noch ein router dazwischen hättest dann würde der das von dem hier adverteist
bekommen dass dieses netz bei dem ist also da fix sich gar nichts zumindest nix von alleine fix
sich da was funktioniert ist innerhalb vom telekom netz sollte alles wunderbar funktionieren
weil die telekom lässt sich garantiert nicht von irgendwelchen bulgarischen routern ihr
eigenes netz adverteisen also direkt connected gewinnt immer also im telekom netz selbst ist
alles ok wenn hier was direkt angeschlossen wäre wäre das wahrscheinlich auch ok weil
das die kürzere route ist es war sicherlich nicht alles davon betroffen es ist sicher auch
ein bisschen die frage wie das so topologisch aufgebaut ist aber diese falsche route wird
überall hin adverteist also im prinzip hat das ganze internet gedacht vor ein paar tagen dass
der bulgarische router jetzt heile vom telekom netz hat es hat schon mal einer versucht eine
die folterung am desex zu propagieren oder es funktioniert ich weiß nur dass diese fehler
öfters mal vorkommen vor ein paar jahren war mal auch das internet ziemlich am wackeln da hat auch
glaube ich irgendein tschechischer provider oder so damals komische dinger adverteist das kommt
regelmäßig mal vor ich würde sagen so einmal vielleicht zweimal im jahr das kommt ab und zu
schon mal vor innerhalb des telekom is läuft ja kein bgp oder nee oder sag mal so man kann bgp
sicherlich auch intern verwenden keine ahnung aber das wissen wir nicht also bei uns weiß ich bei
uns ist intern alles über ospf das interessiert aber halt die anderen provider nicht also wenn
die telekom hier noch 50 50 andere router drinne hätte so hier alter mein gott ist das scheiße
gemacht mega beschissene die telekom hier noch andere router drinne wie die intern miteinander
kommunizieren ist für uns sehr egal das muss uns auch also gerade wenn wir hier irgendwie auf
der seite sind muss uns das ja überhaupt nicht interessieren wie das intern machen
so ich werde jetzt noch mal auf allen routern speichern gegen das noch mal hier en und dann
wie er memory na sagt bäm den gespeichert en memory bäm en wm bäm alles klar und hier
auch noch mal speichern exzellent wunderbar was ist das denn physikal alter was haben die
denn mittlerweile alles in packet tracer eingebaut ich warum kann ich warum habe ich landkarten in
packet tracer warum die man die wollen es echt wissen mit dem tool oder zwischen den
rs routern fritz box manchmal wird mich nichts wundern also in der fritz box an sich bringt
also den switch von der fritz box weil den router mit zweimal dem gleichen netz an unterschiedlichen
ports funktioniert natürlich nicht weil der router keine ahnung hat wann er magischer art
und weise welchen port verwenden soll also du kannst nicht mit einem router routen zwischen
zwei ports mit dem gleichen netz das funktioniert nicht dafür brauchst du switch
so sieht das aus
ich glaube ich gehe jetzt was essen leute es war exzellent dass ihr dabei wart gibt es
irgendjemand den ich hosten kann was macht der frasier so der frasier am start nein der hat
zuletzt vor neun tagen weep games gespielt hoffe ich habe nichts übersehen so habe ich
irgendjemand kleines dem ich folge den hosten kann fox macht den wettbewerb wie kann man
innerhalb von fünf minuten wer schafft es mehr schwachsinn zu schreiben fünf minuten ist
gerade so ich sehe schon richtig hier so mein twitch chat ist abgekackt leute auf dem vorschau
rechner der chat weg in südkorea in südkorea die stehen total auf internet internet cafes
ja wie heißt das da pc banks ist das doch in korea also leute ich hau ab bis denn macht
es gut ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen nice erstream big brain chat wieder am start gewesen